the well you're here to talk about
whatever you want you know
um I like to hear first though from
Emily Barker representing the um Board
oh okay so how's Will 655 as you know
was a pretty beefy bill
and all of House Bill 655 was in house
bill 2. the trailer builds the budget
and so what we've done to make this a
little bit more
uh reasonable from from our community
standpoint is that we took all the
repeal portion of house bill in House
Bill 655 and we took that out
the repeal portion of house bill 655. is
taken out
okay
all that is gone
so House Bill 65 655 is meant to codify
what's going to happen in oplc on the
organizational level and not on the
okay and then House Bill 2
still has those portions of the repeal
in it and this committee will have a
work session on that on Friday at two
o'clock so we're essentially dividing
the bill in half
the oplc portion
and the board portion
okay
thank you so please miss Barker
we need that because I never speak up
enough I'm Emily Baker I'm a physician
and the current president for the Board
of Medicine and I submit submitted a
document that at your pleasure to read
so in the um I believe in
House Bill 2 because this has been
removed from this part of the bill has
been removed from house bill 655.
so um do you have some comments about
the
medical review board can you speak to
that because it says a component that
was in House Bill 655 and we'd like your
input on that yeah sure
the medical abuse subcommittee is
established in statute currently
as a
also comprised of licensees and public
members
and does investigations on complaints
that come in through and right now they
come in through the office of oplc
and
my understanding at least from my read
of hb2 was that that would the intent
was for that to go away
and my second paragraph in my document
lends the boards
support for some version of a panel
to review complaints and assist in
investigations
and I describe what I think is sort of
in the value of a panel and it's similar
to any board where you have more than
one individual who has potential for
expertise to talk about an investigation
and make a recommendation
and whether or not
that continues in the form of where it
stands in statute currently or falls
under the Aegis of the oplc with details
thank you
sorry okay so on Friday that's going to
be part of the discussion at two o'clock
so if you could come back yeah that
would be appropriate would be an
appropriate conversation to have at that
time that's great I will okay thank you
I'm happy to bring some more copies of
the document I have no idea if you're
the exact same group it will be the same
group and um
I think what I'll let I'll let the
committee know when we meet to save this
document for Friday okay
not cut down any more trees exactly
thank you is there anything else that
you'd like to say did you have any
questions about the review of the
applicants the first part of my
oh okay
good morning Representatives Shane
Goulet attorney for the office of
professional licensure and certification
I am board counsel to the Board of
Medicine I just wanted to comment on the
board's position as it relates to the
Authority for issuing licenses there was
a portion in Dr Baker's letter and
submissions as it relates to that it's
unclear as to what that would look like
in totality but the board was concerned
with the ability to review certain
specific applications as it relates to
ones that include past disciplinary
actions in other state criminal history
it's not specific I know that it
illustrates that it would require input
and objective standards that were
created by the board so it might not be
problematic but it was certainly a
concern of the board that certain
applications would absolutely need to be
before the board that contain that type
okay I'll make a note of that
this is the accept committee have any
questions
thank you very much Madam chair
good morning everyone uh pardon my being
a little bit late
um so I'm concerned uh with regard to uh
this the smoothness of the uh the
procedure that we're potentially
embarking on here because uh you know I
I've been on this committee now for 17
years I I saw the
office of Professional Licensing and
certification come in
roughly 10 or 11 years ago
and it was a was a very new operation
there were a lot of rough edges I don't
know how many of you were here at that
time uh but now we're embarking on
something new uh in terms of of
procedure at least and my question is
whether uh what this the workability is
going to be as good as uh as it may be
after you've
taken off the rough edges so to speak
and do do anticipate uh an easy
transition a smooth transition to the
new procedures or are there certain
aspects that uh that you haven't even
encountered yet or haven't thought about
uh and so can you can you speak to that
because I am concerned that especially
um
the the licensees you're you're going to
be working into it
um and you'll have repeated instances of
it because you're doing it every day or
every week some of the people will be
coming in they won't have seen it at all
uh and I'm wondering whether they're
going to go like I am I'm used to
turning right at this corner like the
old milk horse I'm way too old for uh
for this group in terms of Mill courses
but I remember the milk course used to
turn right at this corner doesn't want
to turn left in the new Administration
I I just want to be clear representative
um that I am employed by the office of
professional licensure and certification
but my capacity here and my capacity
within that agency is specific to the
boards uh I represent the boards in
their capacity
um and my testimony here is specific and
relative to the Board of Medicine I can
say from a process and procedure
standpoint as it relates to how the
Board of Medicine has interacted with
the office and I defer to Dr Baker to
correct me if I State anything
inaccurately that it relates to the you
know expeditious
or more uh expedient issuance of
licenses the Board of Medicine is
working directly with the office to
ensure that that occurs kind of hand in
glove and I I think that the board has
been satisfied by the efforts that the
office has been making in relation to
that is as evidenced by the testimony
submitted by Dr Baker in creating
matrices we do have the Board of
Medicine does have a compact which does
allow for the expeditious issuance of
licenses by the office currently the
Board of Medicine is all also authorized
the office to
um
have a matrix if you will on what needs
to come before the board and what does
not to expediate the or to kind of make
the licensing process go faster is that
a fair and accurate assessment of the
if you're make sure I've understand your
question right of whether or not we
feel that we're going to have be able to
work on this easily with the board I
mean we've had with the oplc we're
already working with them and feel
comfortable with their staff and our
made changes and are adapting that
off as well and I imagine
there may be issues and it's one of
those things where I don't know what I
don't know and if something comes up I
think the board has the ability to adapt
with the oplc what I can't say is what
license our licensees would experience
our intent our job is to protect the
public
and whether or not the licensees find it
comfortable and about the role of the
oplc is of secondary importance
so that if we can get our job done well
with the current structure we will work
with it absolutely and I don't have any
follow-up
I don't know how much time you want to
spend on any of this man I'm sure
another three minutes would be good okay
then I'm going to defer until later
thank you okay thank you
so we'll see you on Friday at two
o'clock thank you so much
um I have this card here from David
something Courtney County
okay you oh you're Dr Conway
okay thank you
so will you be here on Friday as well
okay
good morning my name is Elizabeth Eaton
I'm also an attorney with the office of
professional licensure and certification
and I'm here representing three boards
today
um I represent the Midwifery Council and
I have written testimony on their behalf
I'm here for the board of natural
scientists and I have written testimony
on their behalf as well as the Board of
Nursing with again written testimony on
their behalf with the
change here to the bill
some of the testimony may not apply
right now we'd have to kind of go back
and reevaluate but I would love to give
these um this testimony to you on behalf
of these boards and
um I don't know that I need to explain
much more than that okay and this will
be discussed from Friday because this is
to do with the repeal section of the
bill some of it does correct um I would
say that the board of natural scientists
has
concerns about the application review
process similar to The Board of Medicine
and so that would apply even with the
without even when you're taking out the
repeals
because licensing is Shifting in that
first section under oplc
[Music]
um otherwise I'd have to take a look at
what we've written here and and really
okay so anything that so I should say
this is this is the process that
representative McGuire and I have
the house bills 465 Amendment will have
everything that's in House Bill 465 plus
some comments that were made at the last
committee meeting up until the repeal
section
that part of the hospital for 655 will
be taken out of house bill 2. and it
will stand alone on its own
the repeal section we're going to take a
look at that and make comments on that
at any amendments that have to be made
to House Bill 2 will be made as a
non-germanic amendment to a bill that we
will have retained in this committee
right so that
if we don't get it all right the first
time around we can amend whatever
amendments need to be done
we'll do over the summer for the next
year
says that does everybody understand that
okay good thanks certainly I I guess
coming here I didn't know that those
parts were going to be correct you know
and I'm here on behalf of boards who
took votes to send testimony and so I'm
just going to send the testimony as it
is yes uh and then we can go from there
and you'll be here on Friday yes thank
you
okay and is there anyone else that would
like to speak I have a card for Dr
Warner is there anyone else other than
Dr Warner that would like to speak
okay all right would you like to come Dr
Warner we have your email
I want to give time to the committee to
the subcommittee to discuss this so
um do you have any comments in addition
to the email that you sent to us uh yes
I do especially since you're looking at
splitting it this way yeah
um if you were to look in my email there
is an attached document of suggested
edits for the um the bill and especially
they also I have seen the revision
suggested by actually you your name is
on it now
um and
um
there are things that
the board of mental health practice and
the board of psychology I'm speaking I'm
Dr Deborah Warner I'm in Littleton I'm
speaking as an individual I'm very well
informed about these board things having
been involved in boards but I'm speaking
as an individual just want to make it
very clear
there are things that those two boys I
did about 12 years ago about the same
time oplc was generated that were
Advanced and are especially good ways of
conducting board business and things
like protecting patient rights and
medical records privacy which did get
put into this revision as well as other
things like the
um
the protection of the allegation status
and the disclosure about that and things
like that that are very important and I
believe should be promulgated across the
boards and I think it would be good to
include it in the first sections the 310
sections that are being separated out
from the other parts that are the
repeals because I think they're just
very good ways to do this across Sports
some things in the first portion the 310
section that particularly alarmed me are
in the 310 colon 9 where the board the
oplc is allowed to initiate
investigations of its own
and not requiring a board order where
it's structured and has charges to be
investigated and inquired about and that
there'd be limitations to that process
and the concern with that is that oplc
or any state agency that doesn't have
guard rails like that can do
investigations on whim they can do it on
on their own
bias or whatever there could be I think
we have a good functioning oplc office
I'm not charging them with anything but
without it being in the law I think it
could get out of hand and I don't think
we want that to happen so various of my
my things if you were to look at my
attachment that has edits for the three
tens I believe that those are very
germane to the portion that you're
looking at keeping in this Bill thank
you thank you does anyone have any
questions
no okay thank you all right thank you
do you wish to speak uh attorney
osterhound or executive director
Courtney
foreign
you know what I don't need pink cards I
really appreciate the convenience but
this is not like a real this is a
subcommittee hearing so we don't
I'm not going to really save them
perfect
um well then thank you madam chair for
the record my name is Lindsay Courtney
I'm the executive director of The Office
of professional life insurance
certification and with me at general
counsel Douglas osterhout
gotta correct this time
um
so essentially the proposed amendment
would
eliminate all of the proposed repeals
that are presently in 655 and just focus
on the recodification of oplc and 310.
practically I think as I've expressed
before it's quite difficult for
individuals to know where to look when
it comes to oplc's Authority because
it's tucked up before all of the other
technical statutes in
310a1a and so I think recodification is
just necessary in order to provide that
transparency as to what law actually
applies
additionally one of the objectives that
I think oplc has and certainly I think
has been expressed in legislation
throughout the last several years is
that there's a need to streamline the
way we do business in the office and so
this proposed amendment really provides
a consistent regulatory framework for
how the licensing boards are supposed to
operate both with respect to licensing
and with respect to discipline now
because the repeals are not proposed
here there would still be some conflicts
in the law and I think certainly the
boards that do have conflicting
Provisions there would be an opportunity
for them to rely on those statutes to
some extent we'd have to do that legal
analysis but I think it provides a
pathway for us to start streamlining and
consolidating the way we do business and
I think frankly it's pretty necessary
you know given our limited resources
regarding Dr Warner's specific concerns
I we the proposed statute does not
contain specifically the statutory
um
requirements that there be an allegation
and then that's elevated to a complaint
practically that's the way our
investigations are already handled
essentially they are screened there's a
determination of whether or not they can
move forward
um once it's determined that the Acclaim
has been is potentially viable then it
there's an order of formal investigation
in the psychology context that would be
when an order of formal investigation
would issue and be elevated to
complaints so practically I don't see a
distinction
in terms of the guardrails for
investigation I would say the guardrails
are what the guardrails are for the
board and that our investigative
Authority would be limited to to
determining whether or not there's been
a violation of something within the
board's jurisdiction we don't have
plenary powers we're not a police we're
not a law enforcement agency so
certainly there are significant
limitations on what we would be able to
do I'll turn it over to Douglas to see
if he has any other
um items I hate link to adjust
with that I'd be happy to answer any
other questions
I'm hoping that after Friday when we
review the rest of House Bill 2 those
conflicts will go away
you know between the amendment so I hope
you'll be here on Friday I certainly
plan on playing hair party okay great
great great great
uh representative Schmidt
again I I want to consult with the chair
with regard to how much we're going to
get into details here uh and how much is
going to be deferred until Friday uh but
um for those of you who are relatively
recent to the whole process uh you may
not be aware that you know there there
is a history involved in some of this uh
that I'm concerned about and
specifically uh you know the the board
of mental health practice originally
grew out long before I came into the
legislature out of the board of
psychologists okay
and gradually over the years uh in the
somewhat distant past the board of
mental health practice grew up around
what had originally been the board of
psychology
and about roughly 10 years ago the
psychologist came in uh to Edna and they
said with an uh the new bill saying this
is not really working we need to have
our own board and and the LED and this
committee looked at this very carefully
and ultimately determined that we were
going to give the psychologists their
own board again and keep the board of
mental health uh practice intact except
for the removal of the board of
psychology now we're talking about
putting that back together again and I
have real concerns as to whether this is
uh you know a solution in search of a
problem because to some degree to the to
the ASP that to the degree that we are
trying to get more efficient and and and
smoother and easier and more uniform
that there's some theoretical benefit to
that but in the Practical world the
question I have is is it is the return
on investment really justified by the
amount of disruption that may be caused
by this process
and this is something that that I think
we have to give some consideration to to
see whether we're spending a dollar to
get you know uh 50 cents worth of
benefit and whether we're in enhancing
our procedures at the expense of the
practitioners and the public so I want I
want everybody to be mindful of this
particular aspect to see whether we are
we are
getting bang for the buck and and if you
can speak to any of those aspects at
this time I'm I would be happy to hear
that if Friday is better I'm willing to
wait until then as well thank you
representative I I can speak to the fact
that the proposed changes that you speak
of are not in this bill and not in this
proposed amendment they're in hb2
certainly but not in this proposed
amendment this proposed amendment would
impact the current structure of any of
those boards it would just provide a
consistent way that we issue licenses
but licenses in the agency as well as
manage investigations and disciplinary
proceedings
intent of the amendment was to do that
so I think the the purpose of the
amendment is to get house this part of
the the codification of oplc under 310
and to allow them to
go on with that and leave the rest of it
in House Bill 2 so that and that gives
us more time really because we just got
House Bill 2 Thursday gives us more time
to look at those elements in it that are
more complicated and that overlap with
existing statutes so that was the
purpose for the house bill 655 Amendment
Nikki if I may represent him just add
one more Point
um with respect to the licensing uh
process that's proposed in this amended
version of 655
it's consistent with what the large
majority of our boards already do and
that the large majority of our boards
have already delegated the authority to
us to Asia licenses unless there are
obviously questions regarding criminal
history checks which would still be
reviewed under this proposed structure
only a handful of boards still review
applications on a very regular basis
most boards have delegated that to us
because they recognize one that it
largely is just an administrative
function to make sure that all criteria
is satisfied because it's objective and
then two there are serious Workforce
challenges with having to wait every 30
60 90 days to review and possibly issue
licenses so it's consistent with what we
are doing but there have been concerns
raised by the LBA in audits performance
audits as to whether or not boards have
the authority to delegate that Authority
so this way this would essentially clear
up that question
foreign
I think that's very helpful to have this
dissociation as discussed early on that
you've already thought through this to a
considerable degree I think that's very
helpful for us to have confidence that
we're not getting from here to
Manchester by way of Los Angeles okay
I'll be very brief uh shengue attorney
with the office of professional
licensure and certification I'm here on
behalf of the Dental Board the board of
land surveyors the Board of Professional
Engineers and the board of accountancy
the board of accountancy has a written
hmm
I believe the board of accountancies
written testimony speaks for itself uh
to the best of my ability I'll answer
questions as it relates to that as far
as the land surveyors and the
Professional Engineers uh they did meet
yesterday and wanted to put on the
record that they are in opposition to
655 full stop that was the vote that
they gave me to represent to this
committee today as it relates to the
Dental Board they had a few specific
concerns again this is notwithstanding
the amendment because they were not
aware of that that may or may not change
their opinion as it relates to that I
couldn't make any representations as it
relates to that here today but
specifically as it regards the Dental
Board they did have concerns with the
complaint process and procedure and the
vetting of the complaints having the
complaints come into oplc and having
them conduct the investigation without
any input from the board was problematic
for them they view their own
professional expertise and ability to
view those complaints of prime
importance and utilizing those expertise
they are aware that oplc does have the
authority to contract with necessary
experts but that was their input as it
related to that specific concern the
other concern when reviewing the 655
that was currently constructed prior to
the amendment was that there was no
consideration as to what constitute
professional misconduct as it related to
their specific profession so what if
anything they were to utilize so that
was a concern that they noted that also
applies to their reciprocal discipline
because that was in the same repeal
again that is not concerned given the
fact that there's an amendment here
today but they wanted to put that on the
record they also had some concerns that
it related to reciprocity and the
issuances of licenses as many states
they highlight it's specifically Vermont
have different standards so they were
concerned about an individual's ability
or a license ability to go to the
easiest State and then similarly be
situated within this state now I know
there's specific language that has been
authorized about similarly situated in
good standing but they did have concerns
with the definition of what does
jurisdiction mean does that mean you
know within the United States
Continental are we talking about
territories are we talking about
jurisdiction globally so that was some
of their concerns open for questions if
you have any thank you okay and so that
you're going to be here on Friday to
address that I will okay perfect yes Dr
Warner
yes
while she's coming up questioning the
chair uh Journey passed out some
information I have it right here and are
we all supposed to get that yes but I
was going to wait until I was going to
wait till after if that's okay if it has
to do with I'm fine with that you're
you're in control of the situation yeah
thank you
thank you very much I've had a chance to
look at the format that you have for the
amendment I'm looking at page five
um line 31 where it's talking about rule
making Authority uh where the oplc would
be promulgating rules with the advice
and recommendations of the
representative board I would strongly
suggest that you insert the words
with the active collaboration and the
advice okay you're on page five
I'm sorry page five the bottom of the
page
line 31
all fees set forth yes all fees set
forth and RSA 310 colon 5 with the
advice and recommendations of the
respective board I would highly
recommend inserting the words with the
after 310 colon 5 with the active
collaboration and advice and
recommendations of the board the reason
for that is this is more passive and as
it is right now the boards may get a
notice about rule changes with a couple
of days 300
rules and such with a couple of days at
the same time that they're preparing for
a board meeting but if there's active
collaboration then
they would have a chance to go review
with an oplc rule-making person what the
changes are and if they have any advice
and recommendations for that
as it's written it's somewhat passive
that they need to just simply be asked
okay we'll take that into consideration
thank you we'll take it into
consideration thank you very much
thank you
okay I'd like this time for this time
the subcommittee which is representative
Dolan myself and representative
Fitzpatrick to talk about the amendment
and whether or not we want to recommend
it to the committee
I can say to you that representative
McGuire and I have been working on this
together
because we felt that house bill 655
because it's an entirety was also
in-house bill 2.
we wanted to pull out the nuts and bolts
of oplc
and take that out of House Bill 2 and
deal with it with this amended form of
House Bill 655
and then Friday the committee will get
together as a whole to discuss the
uh remaining part of House Bill 655
that's still in-house Bill too is that
I'm trying to make this as easily
understood as possible if you have any
questions no thank you for your for your
work on it and it seems like a
reasonable approach
yeah I've had requests
some spoke some folks who testified
today that that this is uh something
that we ought to retain I don't want to
retain it we're not going to retain it
sorry at least I'm not going to
recommend that we retain it if you want
to make that motion
I will
vote against that motion
don't want to retain or do one or
anything because it's in if we if we
retain this it will stay in House Bill
too so we're going to look at it one way
or the other
right
so by splitting it out
and pull it apart right this is the more
the part that's difficult and the part
that we've heard from a lot of people
has to do with the repeals of the boards
and their authorities
and that part has all been left in house
bill 2.
and we will deal with that starting
Friday well we're dealing with it as we
go along but we'll have a full committee
we'll have a full work committee meeting
on Friday about all those elements of it
so the path is to amend it
exactly
the path is to approve this amendment
no
so with that
um what question of the chair so the the
I think all of us that uh been
confronted with this situation on very
short notice and some of this is
extremely fundamental this is kind of
like ripping something out by the roots
uh and thinking that somehow you can
kind of Pat it on top of the ground and
make it go that that's troubling uh but
also the this involves a lot of
stakeholders and the and the the
well-being and the the benefit of the
people of New Hampshire
um and and to the degree that they are
are you talking about the bill or the
amendment I'm talking about the whole
situation because first of all we had
655 came in came in and it was very
voluminous uh and then suddenly uh we
were confronted by the fact that the
governor had put the all this repeal in
the trailer bill
um and that we all know that has to pass
so the contents of the trailer Bill uh
are extremely troubling to me if we
don't get the Public's input for the
benefits excuse me representative
Schmidt we are talking about the
amendment that we have here we're not
talking about House Bill 2. we're going
to talk about you can talk about health
Bill too but not right now I don't want
to talk about House Bill 2 what I want
to talk about is the the fact that we
have some of the important members of
the public here right now and the
question is are we in any way
short-circuiting this process because
it's so rushed
and we have so little time to do this
that to the degree that the public has
concerns that we will never hear because
the process is so what what concerns and
House Bill and this amendment does the
what concerns do you have this is
codifying what they're doing now
that that it sounds good
I just want to make sure that we don't
skip stuff where the public will not be
able to participate and will not know
and that we won't have time to really
fully this is the second cup
subcommittee meeting and we had a
hearing
did we not we did have a hearing you're
talking you're not talking about the
work session you're talking about the
original hearing we had a hearing we had
we had enough committee meeting that you
didn't attend in February we had a work
session on this and now we have another
subcommittee hearing
I I'm I'm only making sure making sure
that my voice is heard with regard to
the having a thorough process where the
we and the public can really see what's
going on and have time to adjust this uh
and I I think the fact that you and the
chair have brought forward an amendment
that seems to resolve some of the
initial concerns we have I'm very glad
to hear about that the uh but the
concern I have is that the public who
are the practitioners in many cases and
their boards that they have an
opportunity to also be a full partner in
this redo of some very important
statutes uh and and I think I see what's
going in a good direction so I'm glad to
hear that the Friday meeting is going to
take this up again I just want to make
sure we don't get you know kind of the
bums Rush here okay let's remember the
house bill 2 is in the is in Finance
okay so we are not going to
we have really the only thing that we
can do is make recommendations I
understand I understand the difficulty
of the process I just want to make sure
that we at least are looking at it and
that we recognize that we're doing a lot
of important things Even in our
committee yeah so I I think I I'm
hearing a good process beginning I just
want to make sure that we're fully
involved thank you we will thank you for
that comment
so do we have a motion on the amendment
I'll move it you'll move it yeah second
okay
so there's only there's three of us so
we are a quorum and uh
let me see moved by representative
Fitzpatrick
second
uh okay and we have all those in favor
hi okay any opposed
thank you
um so the amendment is being recommended
to the committee that's all this does so
the amendment will be brought forth to
the community this afternoon
okay so this concludes the subcommittee
right
foreign
good morning welcome to Edna
I'm opening the public hearing on
House Bill 84 and I call the sponsor
good morning executive departments and
administration committee thank you so
I'm here today to introduce HB 84. this
bill adds language to RSA 21-p colon 37
which I've given everyone a copy of
and it directs the director of Homeland
Security Emergency Management
to assemble and mobilize a municipal
Emergency Response Team in conjunction
with the Department of Transportation in
order to assist municipalities that have
been impacted by a natural disaster
this Municipal Emergency Response Team
would be comprised of existing staff
that could be mobilized in an instant to
respond to a natural disaster in one or
more municipalities in the state
it's much like when a business has
employees located on each floor of their
company to be floor wardens or fire
wardens that could jump into action if
an emergency occurs at work
a municipal Emergency Response Team
would contact the town or vice versa and
be ready to help provide any necessary
resources that the town may not have at
hand
they could draw from State resources
things like trucks sand gravel signs Etc
and deliver them quickly to where they
are needed
these designated individuals would also
be able to go where the disaster
occurred to immediately view the damage
and help with whatever the town needs if
necessary
and then quickly report back to the
governor so the emergency declaration
process for FEMA can get started
this idea came to me after what happened
in the July 2021 floods in Acworth the
town that one of the towns that I
represent and the surrounding towns
my town was struggling with trying to
locate items like sandbags signage
Gravel Road barriers trucks Emergency
Equipment and all other resources to
deal with the aftermath of this natural
disaster to make roadways passable and
safe especially for emergency vehicles
it took us days
even weeks to locate resources that we
needed
we spent precious time trying to figure
out where to get assistance and who
might be able to help us acquire the
temporary resources that we needed
and although we were in touch with then
director Jennifer Harper of Homeland
Security emergency management the
response time and help from that office
was painfully slow
now I do know that there is a municipal
Mutual Aid Society but a town must be a
dues-paying member and they do not
always have the Emergency Equipment and
resources that you might be seeking in
fact there were pretty much of no use to
our town after the floods hit
we called them and they didn't have the
items we were seeking specifically Road
barriers and signs surrounding towns had
similar problems we were having in
dealing with their flooding and their
resources were being used for their own
emergencies so they couldn't lend them
out to us
we did after a while get some great help
from dot director of operations David
rodrigue but that was after much
searching for contact information the
dot was very helpful to us in the end
but we had wished we had gotten them on
board to our needs much sooner
they're also very helpful in assisting
with notifications for road closures
yes every town should have a checklist
of what to do in an emergency as well as
numbers for who to call
Acworth as well as other towns has an
emergency plan and we found difficulty
when actually implementing it because
these lists can get out of date quickly
people change jobs phone numbers change
and some situations you just cannot plan
for
it would have been better to have state
resources to help immediately and at the
ready when we needed it and when things
are in such a tumult where whole roads
have washed away and infrastructure is
totally destroyed smaller towns with
part-time help and small road
maintenance crews could really use some
immediate help from the state
and that is what this changed to statute
seeks to fix
so I hope that you will consider this a
worthwhile addition to the state statute
that could truly be helpful when the
disaster strikes especially to our
smaller rural towns and with that I'd be
happy to take any questions or go over
the um
the language of the bill
which actually adds a new paragraph to
uh the statute which I handed out to you
this morning thank you thank you are
there any questions from the committee
representative leckis
thank you uh just wondering so for
um it's 21 P 37 to go into effect does
that require that the governors declared
a state of emergency or does this take
effect in other circumstances no what
this does is that
um the it would it would say that the
the Department of Homeland emergency
um
Homeland Security and Emergency
Management work in cooperation with
other departments such as the Department
of Transportation to name some
individuals who would be on an on a
emergency response team and that if a
natural disaster strikes a flooding or
um you know
a tornado fire explosion whatever that
that team could be put into a action
right away to either contact the town or
have the town contact them so that there
would be resources made available
immediately to the municipality
representative Rhoda and then I bear
thank you
understanding the the necessity for this
bill
as it relates to what was currently
being done because I would think that
if a tone
were to need assistance from
other departments
under a natural disaster it's not like
something you know
I mean a natural disaster is a big deal
people know what those that those exist
and that's the purpose of Homeland
Security and the the Departments that
you refer to I just don't know why this
is needed
can you explain that please well I mean
just judging from what happened in my
own town there was really no coordinated
effort
put in place on the onset of of this
natural disaster and we were really
scrambling for days and even like I said
in in two weeks to uh get the resources
that we needed that we didn't have on
hand
for our town to be able to deal with
such Devastation in roads being washed
away completely and damaged to a point
of Disappearing so my point is that this
would have a team assembled already
that you
would be able to draw upon
and would be there to help a town
instead of
you know having to scramble around for
days and weeks to get the help that we
needed
the next speaker is from Dot and may be
able to explain the differences because
I think that is an important issue other
questions specifically for
representative Aaron representative
O'Brien uh thank you madam chair uh
thank you representative for taking my
question
uh can you tell us about your town and
in context of an emergency disasters
they're all one it doesn't really matter
thank you I mean a blizzard can be a
complication okay yeah when it does
occur but
does your Town require people to go to
additional schoolings for the incident
command system and do the different type
of networking and you know to learn some
of these things or do you rely heavily
on the state to send you in the right
direction
thank you for your question first of all
my town of Acworth is a town of 850
people
we have a road crew of three
we have 55 miles of road that we
maintain with that road crew of three
we don't we don't rely on the state if
we don't have to
certainly but in this particular
instance when we had this this
absolutely devastating flooding in July
2021 where entire roads were gone
overnight
we did not have the resources or
manpower to deal with that on our own
and
it yes we have people in our town who
are trained in Emergency Management we
have uh you know our our volunteer
firemen we have our EMTs all of that
people who are trained but when you
don't have the resources of uh Road
signage to keep people from driving off
the side of the road and you don't have
uh you know the gravel or uh the um
sandbags and that kind of thing
available to you as a small town the
only place to turn to would either be
through a mutual Aid Society which we do
have access to but they were busy with
their own issues of flooding
or the state and it took us a while
before we can get in touch with the
state to get the resources that we
needed in place
so it my idea is that if they had an
emergency response team in place that
they could come to us right away it
thank you
uh representative a bear or is that for
foreign
thank you madam chair um representative
I looked up while you were speaking and
the state has had a division of
Emergency Services since 1999.
um you mentioned I believe a contact
that I understood was in homeland
security but did your town contact
emergency services which I has been
aligned with my town for many years
do you know if they contacted I'm sure
they contacted whoever they needed to
contact and it was
we had very big difficulty in getting
people to come to help us and get the
resources that we needed
interested to hear from the dot
gentleman to see what could what could
we thank you thank you anyone else all
right thank you very much representative
thank you David Rodrigo
foreign
chair and members of the committee
um for the record my name is David
rodrigue I am the assistant commissioner
for New Hampshire Department of
Transportation
um I want to start by just explaining
that this this particular storm was very
devastating particularly to the town of
Acworth
um I've been responding to these uh
events for for more than 15 years and I
have never seen an individual Community
suffer so much damage and it probably
goes back to the Alstead floods since
we've seen a community that suffered so
much damage and I apologize to the
representative that it took longer than
than it should have for her to feel that
the town had the attention
of the the state of New Hampshire
um I want to start by just walking
through when events like this this occur
um they often come on very very quickly
and in a matter of four to six hours
sometimes a little more sometimes uh a
little less parts of our stay can be
devastated roads roads are washed out
bridges are washed out emergency
services are struggling to find out how
they can get to people's homes to to
help them
um to make sure people are safe I can
tell you from a DOT perspective we
become hyper focused on responding to to
those events that that hyper Focus
becomes on our state roads doing our own
assessments and doing our own response
at the same time often the the Emergency
Operations Center is activated by the
division of Homeland Security and
Emergency Management
dot that they they followed the incident
command structure and they they have set
up several emergency support functions
dot sits at the Emergency Operations
Center and fills two of those emergency
support functions one is for
transportation and one is for public
works and in engineering this type of of
damage falls under Public Works and in
engineering there is a robust process in
in place for communities through their
their Emergency Management directors to
reach out to Homeland Security through
local Liaisons and during calls that are
often scheduled to ask for resources
that they need and at that point our
folks who are at the Emergency
Operations Center work to match
communities up with with the resources
that they need I can tell you for a town
like Acworth in the damage that they
they suffered three days four days it's
it's harrowing one week two weeks it's
harrowing to fully comprehend what's
happened to your community and how how
to to go forward
we have worked with the public works
Community for for many years to
establish what we call Public Works
Mutual Aid and the idea of Public Works
Mutual Aid is just like a fire
department when they face a a fire that
is beyond their local capabilities they
call on neighboring towns to help them
Public Works Mutual Aid is supposed to
work very much the the same way
um not all communities are members of
Public Works Mutual Aid the cost to be a
member is 25 to to join
um and I'm not sure if that's a
recurring annual fee or not but it's
it's 25 information is available for
that from t-squared technology
um group at UNH works with with Public
Works communities and also the New
Hampshire Municipal Association that
that group is not as mature as we would
like to see it and and
um representative Aaron is right on that
that group has a very difficult time
responding immediately with with
supplies and resources to to help
um I want to tell you unfortunately the
D.O.T has a hard time responding as as
much as as well as we would like I for
years have worked with others at D.O.T
and others have have tried to get a
small group in our design team or our
our Highway design Bureau to help us
with with uh state roads and quick
response just a little bit of the the
numbers of people that we're talking
about Statewide that that would be able
to help with this and we were looking
right now the department overall
typically has 156 civil engineers that's
in Concord and Statewide
um I'm sorry we we typically have a
little over 200 currently we have 156 we
have 43 vacancy rates or 43 vacancies
and that's over uh 22 vacancy rate
and in our Highway design Bureau we
typically have 60 or we currently have
61 people we have 25 vacancies or a
vacancy rate of 30 percent
for our winter maintenance people who
are out there right now who are the
crews that are distributed around the
state that drive the trucks in and the
the equipment
um
currently we have 175 vacancies or just
over 25 percent
well I agree 100 with what
representative is Aaron Aaron is asking
for in this bill I fear that we would be
making a promise that we are not staffed
to to keep even when we're we're fully
staffed we those people become fully
engaged in our own roads
123a flows through Acworth and just
south of Acworth and Alstead from this
very same storm that road is currently
alternating one-way traffic
awaiting a project to be designed and
hopefully funded by by FEMA to restore
that to two-way traffic the the truth of
the matter is that it does take us us
time to respond and we do so to to the
best of of our ability
I do think that there are current laws
that allow some of what representative
Aaron is asking for to happen to to
happen
um I also want to point out that as we
respond to emergencies in these very
same areas
we rely very heavily on contractors and
we rely very heavily on local businesses
local gravel pits for for sand and and
so forth and and those things
um what I would really ask for and we
should probably find a way to provide it
on our own is to work better to together
to strengthen Public Works Mutual Aid
and to strengthen our process to make
sure as as these events uh occur
um the Emergency Management directors
are connected with Homeland Security and
we're getting the the request for for
resources and able to respond but I just
want to to add no matter how good of a
job we do
um 48 Hours three days after a store it
takes time for us to to figure out the
full extent of
um the damage that we suffered during
these events and I'd take any questions
all right thank you very much I just
want to confirm that you're saying you
think you have the
basic structure to respond to an
emergency although probably not as fast
as some people might like but you're
currently understaffed and when an
emergency hits you're stretched in that
area
I think the structure through Homeland
Security and and Emergency Management is
excellent I think the Emergency
Operations Center works very well we
have dot representatives in there that
can help work with communities to to
find resources but yes it takes longer
than than communities would like during
those times absolutely okay
representative schuett and then Schmidt
and a bear and O'Brien
thank you madam chair
um Mr rodrigue I'm curious
um has your department done any kind of
Outreach to try and expand this Public
Works Mutual Aid id idea
we have we there there is a a public
works Association that the department is
a part of there's also the board of
directors for that Association that the
department is a part of we work very
closely with court bloomquest from the
city of Keene who kind of of lead leads
that group but the the truth is at the
end of the day what public works and
highways communities and
communities fund us oftentimes not an
acworth's case but communities
oftentimes resource us just that are a
little lower than other priorities in
their communities
um and well from a fire perspective we
think nothing about jumping in to
respond when the when these types of
events happen if if if a road agent
wants to respond they need the support
of their local officials the questions
of are we really going to get reimbursed
if we send people over there come into
play the questions of are we really
going to get our pipe back if we send
that over come into to to play this
should be no questions of that and we
need to do a better job working with the
public works Association
um to help strengthen that that part of
our response so it's just as clean as it
Schmidt
thank you madam chair
um so uh this is also obvious that it's
kind of like you know if it's icy
outside don't go outside because you
might fall if you fall you got a problem
uh but the question is for us is what
does this bill do that is not already
Common Sense the governor has
extraordinary Authority as you know in
emergencies to do whatever is necessary
the question is how quickly can you can
he or she respond with the apparatus
that we have which is what you've been
talking about what does this bill do
that that is not just words on paper
that will not be implemented any better
than what we currently have
foreign
this bill may put requirements on the
DLT that we can't physically meet and
they said it an expectation that that we
have resources
um that we don't necessarily have that
that being said the the fact that we're
talking about this bill is is a clear
indication to me as has been suggested
that we can work better with the
communities to be more prepared so
um part of what's listed in this bill is
is signs and traffic controlled devices
we again we become stressed in these
times without having signs and traffic
control devices we we go pretty far to
to get those we will provide them to to
a community if we have them and as the
requests come through the EOC but maybe
there are some things we could do if we
had some funding to put together some
trailers with device with some devices
that could be available to go to
communities when they need them so there
is some more proactive work we could do
if we had the the funding to to do that
I I understand the reality is it's it's
kind of like you know if you've got
triplets then Mom and Dad are going to
have to triage right if you all three of
them need something simultaneously you
don't have enough hands you're always
going to need one more shovel one more
fire truck one more if you have a real
emergency so what does this bill do that
you can't already do if you just had
more people
because you're never going to have
enough people for every imaginable
emergency what does this bill do that we
so what what this bill requires is that
team be mobilized be ready to go and be
mobilized in the event of that that an
emergency occurs we do not have that
team available and ready to mobilize at
this point so that's what the bill would
do
thank you madam chair
thank you for taking my question
so what I'm hearing is that you need at
your level and with mutual Aid and with
the DOT
you guys need to be reinforced more than
what this bill would do to your answers
to representative Schmidt
yes this bill puts the burden and the
requirement on the D.O.T with the
resources that we have
um we would not be able to to meet the
requirement of this of this bill with
the resources that we have without
expense to responding to our own D.O.T
um assets and without the expense of
continuing the the work that we're doing
on the projects that that we have in the
so has your department reported to the
state that you guys just need more more
expanded support or I've talked to your
team several times and I know that you
you need four guys to close and exit so
if we have a fuel truck run down a hill
spill fuel into the river I assume that
you guys have access to the pads needed
to throw into the river to absorb the
fuel
and to to triage there
um but you're what you're saying is you
need more so I just don't to
representative Schmidt's points I don't
see how this this bill fixes what the
real root cause problem is unless you
can shed some light thank you right you
you are correct this bill does not fix
that that root problem just do follow
through with your emergency scenario if
if that happens that's the fire
department that responds to do that type
of incident with the fuel spill and and
would arrest that we may respond to help
with traffic control and we may respond
to take care of anything within our own
infrastructure or make sure that as part
of the cleanup things are taken care of
within our own infrastructure but our
responsibility doesn't extend beyond we
limit our responsibility to our roadway
Network him right away
okay uh representative O'Brien was next
if you still have a question thank you
madam chair I might have a couple but
I'll keep them focused please thank you
okay uh in the situation that
representative Aaron has brought up you
know and I understand there's a
difference between Rainbow City and the
actual disaster it may take years to get
the road finally repaired but I think
what representative Aaron is really
talking about
where was the state representative like
in other words now just to give you the
usual caveats I was a deputy chief in
Nashua if I needed something do you
think I'm going to call on the crane and
be on the phone for an hour trying to
get a crane if I needed a building to be
torn down I delegated that Authority
through it against in the command system
do you have that in other words will you
at least send a supervisor to look at
the situation then say okay we can
handle this we can handle that and be
part of the command system and
furthermore this committee voted to make
uh Public Works First Responders
so therefore I think you have that you
know ability to fall within the incident
command system
so yes so that's that's a a good
question right so we we do that as I
explained we we've filled the desk at
the Emergency Operations Center and we
take the request for resources as they
they come in as our supervisors we are
focused on our state roadway Network in
responding to that and making sure that
the bridges people drive over to to get
to those locations can be used safely
they typical typically suffice suffer
damages as well and again we become
focused on our own infrastructure first
okay yeah I'll take that it just seems
to be a gap within and if we're going to
include you as part of the First
Responders then I think there needs to
be better training along that type of
lines in other words the fire chief
police chief or whoever is the IC
Incident Commander doesn't need to make
the phone calls he needs to delegate and
say to like dot you're handling this
yeah you get a bridge in trouble we got
this we're going to block it off good I
don't want to see you again until it's
done you know and that's traditionally
how it operates
and and that's a gap that we are hoping
Public Works Mutual Aid will help fill
so that's that's your communities you're
asking so you're not taking the D.O.T
from Route 10 and with with so many
vehicles per hour to a much lower volume
of road to to take care of that problem
there
the the perception is we got so many
people you just take them from somewhere
else right so during this this same
storm that again devastated Acworth we
had damage and Gilmanton we had damage
in Loudon we had damage to Alton so the
perception that we can take people from
other places can we app at Peril at
peril
and thank you for answering the
questions and Madam chair I'm going to
end it at that I think when we get to
Executive we could peel the banana on
this one all right thank you
representative
no okay representative leckis thank you
um so my question is if you had more
resources or maybe some resources
dedicated to responding to the sort of
emergency as you described maybe
trailers full of stuff or whatever
um is there
you know would you respond better and in
the way this bill wants do you have the
authority to do it and would you
actually do it is it completely a
resource issue or is there you know
would this bill help if you had more
resources
our our belief my belief is that the
emergency management system that we have
in this day works and and works well the
homeland security with the Emergency
Operations Center and bringing us all to
together works and works well my
position is it is the Public Works
Mutual Aid that we should be
strengthening and that all communities
should be supporting to help fill this
this Gap thank you okay thank you
representative
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question
um my assistant manager lived in Acworth
and it was horrible
so thank you for the bill
um my question to you is do you see more
and more natural disasters happening
impacting our roads
as time goes by are you seeing more or
less we we we see more so there there's
no doubt that we have more intense
storms more frequently than than we have
historically we also have more developed
property and more infrastructure and
more people pushed out into areas that
they haven't been in the past that they
need access to follow-up manager
follow-up
so
what I'm hearing and I maybe I didn't
hear you correctly is that there's
really not a system right now to
prioritize requests that come in oh
there is
excuse me I'm so um
that there is a a very robust system so
again the Emergency Operations Center
activates they they have a system web
EOC that that gets populated we respond
to to that location request come in from
communities and there is a targeted
um response to make sure that those
those requests are satisfied as soon as
as possible in this in this case what
we're hearing from from Acworth and
representative Aaron is it wasn't enough
they they needed boots on the ground to
help when this storm unfolded the the at
as it was unfolding I was in the field
looking at state state assets and damage
to to State assets not not in in Acworth
but we were available to take the calls
and respond
but it's difficult for the town to know
exactly what they need exactly where
they need it and to come up with a plan
with something as as devastating as that
so what I hear from Acworth is they
needed boots on the ground with them
with their Emergency Management director
helping to respond and the the solution
that's being presented is that should be
the D.O.T that comes in and supports
them on the ground at their at their
location the current structure would
support that would be Public Works
Mutual Aid which is a significantly
larger pool Statewide that would fold
that Gap and admittedly we have some
work to do to improve that process
thank you representative Gerhart thank
you madam chair in the interest of time
I'll just take a yes or no on this are
there reports as to the actions that you
did or didn't take for incidences that
occurred such as this flood yes thank
you okay excellent any other questions
representative schuette
thank you madam chair just just one more
quick one I think uh would you say that
the problems encountered in this
incident have spurred your department to
I I get I am very proud of our emergency
response before and after this this
event
um so no I don't think it has caused us
to to respond more quickly I I think it
brings to light that if there is an
expectation that D.O.T is staffed to
send a purse even one person never mind
the team to each individual Community as
an emergency is unfolded or in the
immediate aftermath we are not resourced
to do that and we do not and cannot
provide that that service if if we can
can get there days later one or more of
us become focused because it's not till
oftentimes two or three days later that
you know exactly where the the damage is
concentrated which communities are hard
artist and and and need the work we can
provide them a little level of support
but again not that that team to to come
in ideally we would be leveraging just
as dot does and and our response we
leverage uh contractor Partners private
contractor Partners that's why it's so
important that we have our rented
equipment program and work with
contractors to rent their equipment and
sometimes their people and equipment to
respond to to these things that's how
we're able to do it more quickly not
with our people
towns need engineers and other other
folks from the private sector to come in
and help as well to fill that Gap thank
you
thank you very much thank you is there
anyone else who wishes to testify on
House Bill 84
all right seeing now I'm going to close
the public hearing
and since
we are running late I will go into the
public hearing on House Bill 127. I do
expect to vote on that bill this
afternoon in our scheduled executive
session
okay thank you
um I'm Tony luckis representing
um Hillsborough District 38 the towns of
Hudson and Litchfield
so House Bill 127
is identical to house bill 275.
um
initially came in in 2021 and became a
2022 bill which I think it was retained
that passed the house and the Senate and
was vetoed at that time by the governor
the reason for this
is the question of
you know who has to okay who represents
the people
if there's going to be an extended state
of emergency clearly the governor needs
some power to act on his own to deal
with an emergency in the moment we we're
not a very rapidly responding
organization
um and what this bill allows is the
governor to declare a state of emergency
for up to 21 days and renew it up to
three times so that's a total of 84 days
after that point I think that you know
to continue it beyond that the
representatives the people both the
house and the Senate should both agree
that it needs to extend
and that's based on actually what's in
the Constitution if you look at part one
article 37
in the government of this state the
three essential Powers there to there to
wit the legislative executive and
judicial
ought to be kept separate from and
independent of each other as the nature
of a free government will admit
or is this consistent with that chain of
connection that binds the whole fabric
of the constitution in one indissoluable
Bond of unity and Union anonymity and um
so that recognizes there can be some
situations where that won't be followed
but
um
it should be kept separate to the extent
it as at all possible and what happens
during a state of emergency
is the um certainly the legislative
branch has dropped out of the picture
and that Duty basically goes to the
executive
and at least some of the judicial branch
as well
um and it is true that there are
situations where for at least a period
of time that's necessary but as soon as
possible
um that should end
and so even in the recent uh emergency
we had related to uh covet pandemic
you know this the legislature met in
less than 84 days
and almost every emergency that we've
ever every emergency ever had has been
shorter than that and trying to think of
emergencies which might extend beyond
that
you know even if something disastrous
happened with let's say the Seabrook
Nuclear Power Plant
given what's happened elsewhere we the
legislature should be able to meet on
the western part of the state partly
given weather patterns even if Fukushima
which was you know much worse than
anything Seabrook could do partly
because
um you know more reactors and everything
it was safe to be within the distance we
have in the state from Seabrook you know
in less than that amount of time
so the main difference between the
current statute of 445 and this is that
currently the legislature has the right
to choose to meet
and to vote to end the state of
emergency
and that would require a majority of
both the house and the Senate and also
overcoming the inertia of choosing to
meet it's I mean it's it's a normal
human and organizational thing that
if you don't have to do something
difficult and you don't have to take
responsibility for something there's a
tremendous Temptation not to do so and
to leave it off on someone else in this
case it would be the legislature I would
say being derelict in their
responsibility and leaving it to the
governor and it's just natural that
that's a tendency for people to do
um what this would do is after a maximum
of 84 days if the legislature felt that
the emergency should extend it would
have to meet and have to have a majority
vote to extend the well in effect to
declare the emergency again
and I believe that you know that's
constitutional it's reasonable and
practical
um you know even in a very bad emergency
that should be possible
the other issue is that through a
process that I don't fully understand we
had House Bill 417 and committee
conference was deadlocked some other
people here were on that
and during that there was a call down to
OLS to get any Amendment drafted and
what they came up with was something
that nobody on the committee conference
wanted however somehow that's what ended
up being included in hb2 in 2021 and I'm
not going to go into details but there
are some
uh problems potentially with that it
says the the governor shall you know
after 90 days the governor shall call
pursuant to Art part two in article 50
the New Hampshire Constitution and
address a joint session of the general
court and she'll provide a written copy
of the address to all members of both
chambers within five anyway it goes on
and so it's you know there again it
would take both the house and the Senate
and the state of emergency
but what's currently in statute requires
that um that there be a joint session
called within 90 days
so adopting 275 you know this bill would
not I'm sorry 127 too many versions
um would not add some new requirement
that the legislature meet to extend the
state of emergency
but there's a requirement now in statute
that the legislature meet within 90 days
which is about the same amount of time
I mean the real substantive difference
to think about is you know I mean all
these bills we're hearing here for them
to go into effect requires a majority of
both the house and the Senate just to
pass normal bills
and I believe that to
um in fact suspend part of the
Constitution if we want to continue that
a long time it should require at least
the same threshold of the house and the
Senate a majority in both voting to
continue the state of emergency because
I think that's much more serious
than just passing you know any of the
bills we pass and the people need to be
represented in that process thank you
thank you representative are there any
questions
representative Schmidt
thank you madam chair thank you so uh
you referenced earlier in your statement
that
um that they're in a state of emergency
tends to elicit a response from the
responsible authorities but is it not
also equally the case that such
situations lend themselves to uh
um
people yelling for the sake of
attracting attention to themselves not
to solving the emergency
thank you I mean people will do all
sorts of things
um you know people do that in response
to requests for bills
but that doesn't mean that we should
appoint the governor's dictator and the
legislature should step down and not
bother legislating
is that really the alternative
I'm so glad to hear
are there any other questions
representative O'Brien thank you madam
chair and thank you representative for
taking the question
um
coming from the emergency
field so to speak you can only report to
one God
okay that's the best way that the
situation works you haven't got other
people that's why we delegate as we
mentioned with the incident command
system and everything do you find it
that would be counterintuitive I mean at
least the governor's establishing he uh
has declared an emergency if it goes too
long it sometimes they do but when I'm
trying to get at you need just to have
one person able to make that when you
get the house involved and the Senate
involved then it starts to become like
perhaps maybe political I I understand
uh the issue
um uh two things one is the legislature
I don't see the legislature
micromanaging the emergency response the
only thing that they're deciding in this
case is after 84 days is it appropriate
for the this to remain an emergency
where the governor had continues those
emergency Powers
um it's either yes or no on that and if
the governor is permitted to continue
then he'll have the emergency Powers he
normally has and he'd be the one God to
report to so to speak
um
and and everything's political I mean
everything we do is political making all
the decisions are political
and a decision on whether the governor
can maintain extraordinary powers
that were you know put in effect some
parts of the Constitution of bands yes
that's a political question but it's a
question where the the people of the
state deserve to have their
representatives
um involved in making that decision and
I think it's critical that both the
house and the Senate have to agree to it
I mean the house is the body closest to
the people most representative of the
people and they should have to agree as
well as the Senate if if an
extraordinary thing such a state of
emergency is going to go on for that
long and it is allowed to go on for a
long time so if there are early on you
know confusion and and concerns and
political hoo-ha or whatever
um there's time for that to to work its
course so it's not going to block the
what exactly is the most egregious thing
that a governor could do during a state
of emergency I mean that's speculation
I'm not going to get into
um you know you can imagine whatever you
like that's not really a question an
appropriate question to ask represent of
your heart I'd like to mention that we
have from our researcher a list of
states of emergency yes a list of states
of emergencies what they happened and
the history of Emergency Management
legislation at least the most recent
ones uh and representative Poole do you
have a question I do thank you madam
chair and thank you representative
did you say that that
what you're asking for in 127 is already
in law but it's 90 days instead of 84
days am I missed that's not quite
um well it's already in law is that
um the governor is required to call a
let me find it here
uh what was required to call a joint
session of the legislature
um every 90 days you know after the
first 90 days and if it Contin the
legislature agrees to continue goes
beyond that and that's similar to the 84
days in this bill the the main
difference is
in the current statute to end the state
of emergency it would take both the
house and the Senate a majority of them
voting to end it
that if this bill were to become law it
would require a majority of the house
and the Senate to continue it
yes and I'd like to mention that within
90 days after the Declaration of the
covet emergency the house met and voted
on ending the state of emergency and
that motion failed
right in fact I can respond that's true
and you know I'm not saying that all
states of emergency should end after 84
days I'm saying after that period of
time
you know the representatives of people
have a duty to make a decision on
true
because I'm trying to read this and
listen to you and I'm not doing well so
after 84 days
the legislature meets
and decides that it will continue
does that continue for another 84 days
is that if
um actually what happened what an effect
happens is
um I mean the legislature could meet
any time during those 84 days to end it
if they both you know both bodies
decided to end it but at 84 days it
actually the governor can't continue it
what really happens is that the
legislature meets and declares a state
of emergency the bill gives the
legislature the ability to declare one
for up to 90 days and that's rather than
the 21 for the governor because it's
more overhead with the legislature to
meet
and then
um you know if if after 84 days Plus 90
days the legislature thinks it needs to
continue they'd have to meet again and
extend it and that's there's no limit to
how long the legislature could choose to
other questions
all right thank you very much
representative thank you
foreign
thank you madam chair members of the
committee my name is Tom Manion I'm
representing Hillsboro One Pelham I'm
here to speak in support of hb127
despite a predecessor bill being vetoed
last term the governor in his 2023
inauguration speech had this to say
in New Hampshire we distilled decision
making down to the lowest possible level
of power empowering individuals to make
their voices heard at the local level
where their voice is the greatest
sounds clear-cut that decision making
should be in the hands of the people
as one of the largest representative
bodies in the world the voices from the
local level are Amplified through their
representation better here than any
other state
if our districts require that a state of
emergency continue then this body would
be most knowledgeable about the
individual circumstances and can vote
accordingly to extend it
at the federal level since the passing
of the National Emergency acts in 1976
the Office of the President has declared
79 National emergencies and 42 are still
in effect to this day
the structure for ending these
emergencies is the same as New Hampshire
requiring the legislative branch to vote
to end them
and since the gridlock is not uncommon
at any level of government they persist
it's troubling to think a governor that
may run for president is comfortable
with retaining such power in his current
position and what that mean what that
could mean for the country should they
win a presidential run
the default state for any citizen should
always be freedom from government
interference in their lives emergency or
otherwise and this body should have to
convene and act on behalf of the desires
of our constituents to disrupt that
freedom only if absolutely necessary it
should not be a battle to return Liberty
to Granite Staters and this bill
corrects that I will ask the committee
to OTP hb-127 and I'm willing to take
any questions
thank you are there any questions
all right seeing none thank you very
much
is there anyone else who wishes to
all right seeing none I will I will
close representative already speaking on
House Bill 127.
I will close the public hearing on House
nervous against
um
what
I understand
all right uh under the circumstances I
think we should go into executive
session
for House Bill 127
representative leckis you have a motion
uh yes I move on to pass for House Bill
127. a second okay we have a motion and
a second you
I I think I just did
um
and then just to reiterate I mean you
know having a state of emergency and
suspending the normal legislative and to
some extent constitutional process is
something that is
truly extraordinary and should only be
done if absolutely necessary and only
for as long as absolutely necessary 84
days for that's a long time I actually
would have preferred somewhat less but
that was a reasonable compromise so
um and I think that it's critical if
it's going to continue beyond that
um that both the both bodies the house
and the Senate have to agree as they do
for any bill
um that'll continue after that thank you
okay represent Simon Jewish to speak to
your second uh yeah just briefly I would
add to that just because sometimes it's
easy to wrap your mind around it's
almost three months so it's a very long
time for the governor to have that kind
of levity and we do have a
responsibility to our constituents to
weigh in their concerns as well so okay
yes representative O'Brien well thank
you madam chair I was going to speak on
the bill if it is open at this time uh
and I myself am not going to support it
uh we're talking about very rare events
and I think in this particular situation
I think we all can remember what we went
through with the covet strain and that
seemed to be precipitated into
discussing this particular thing and I
hate bringing up and changing law and
rules of the Constitution when you're
using the example of something as
radical as the covet maybe it would be
better to discuss this at a like a later
date when there was nothing and just
looked at the true merits whether it's
an emergency or not but I think at the
political women of the people I think
people understand when an emergency can
go too far and sometimes it may not go
far enough so
the way it is right now I don't have any
particular problem with the governor
declare in the state of emergency uh
it's like in previous testimony we hear
uh my experience you know with fires and
different things a minute can seem like
an hour and in an emergency situation
clean up when you get into the recovery
that's all coveted into uh trying to get
things back to normal and it can be
years to get things back to normal and
is not covered still a ball around the
chain so again whereas
this bill I don't know I wonder if it's
contaminated by the covert clause
and I would just like to keep it just
basically discussing the merits and I
would feel much more comfortable at a
later date bringing that forward thank
you representative Schmidt did you have
I do have a comment
no one else does so I appreciate the
attempt to Tinker with the current
statute it may be a slight Improvement
but the bottom line is in my opinion
that we confronted a 100 Year event
we haven't seen anything like it since
the
famous Spanish flu as it's misnamed
and all things considered I think the
governor did a responsible job under a
difficult difficult situation and and
largely I believe that the people of New
Hampshire uh recognized a an a seminal
event
and responded appropriately and that
most of their furore was generated by
people who either didn't understand the
situation or didn't acknowledge the
reality of it and it was demagogue to
death by some people thank you
representative I I'm entitled to make my
statement you are not entitled to impugn
their motives however some people I said
okay some people and and this is is not
worth the trouble of going forward in my
opinion I will be voting against it
thank you
representative uh a bear because you
haven't had a shot yet
okay thank you madam chair in the spirit
of discussion I will be supporting HB
127 100
I can tell you in it is the exclusive
one reason why I ran for office and why
I'm here and I'd also like to say that
what I've experienced and seen is that I
have a business with 50 employees
fortunately we were deemed essential
what was told for us for a state of
emergency closing down for a few weeks
turned into
weeks and weeks where we lost in
Massachusetts and New Hampshire
commercial tenants at least 10 different
tenants with an average of three to five
employees each if our business had not
been deemed essential we would have lost
another 50 employees in our company
would have closed so I will support HB
127 100 thank you okay representative
Gould
thank you madam chair I just want to
make sure again I'm understanding so at
the end of the 90 days the governor has
to call The Joint session and then the
legislature has to vote to agree to
continue it no under current law the
legislature
he the governor has to call The Joint
session and the legislature I'm not sure
if they have to vote on it but their
vote will be to end the state of
emergency thank you my dyslexia Madam
chair I said that backwards so so I
understand correctly that at the end of
the 90 days the legislature
automatically goes in and can end the
state of emergency under the current law
correct thank you
okay
I'm sorry
representative grotta I'm sorry I didn't
excuse me
so I am not going to support House Bill
127 because we have this Authority
already and this is really for me
splitting hairs and it's not and it's
not as if the governor is um it is a
dictator and um he um has very limited
powers if you compare him to other
Governors and he does have access to the
agencies that are the ones who work
during these during these crises and
therefore I do believe that in these
situations that position has
the ability to weigh decisions carefully
and since the house can meet to
terminate the State of Emergency on
their own this is not necessary thank
you all right thank you representative
uh like us our assignment
all right uh thank you just uh to
respond to some of the comments um
yeah actually the last one I you know
the governor nor under normal
circumstances has very limited powers
but under a declared state of emergency
as very extensive powers and uh
um you know I'm I'm not and and this is
not well the covet situation brought
this statute to people's attention
because I didn't even know it was there
and many people I've talked to didn't
this is not about whether the covet
emergency was handled correctly or not
that's not my concern and actually I am
fairly confident that if this law were
in place prior to covid that the
legislature probably would have met and
probably would have voted they may very
well have voted to extend the state of
emergency that's not what this is about
it's the legislature
has to take responsibility for it and in
one hand it's you know representing the
people and if representing them in
passing bills requires both bodies to go
along with it you know for something I
see is much more serious they should as
well and the other thing is at that
point the legislature actually if they
just vote to extend it are taking
they're taking the governor's back
you know they're helping to support him
in what he believes is necessary and and
I think that's important
um
see what else and it it's you know this
is not brought on because of political
whatever you know there's no coveted
clause in this bill
um but but the only reason it's in close
proximity to covet is that this hasn't
been used since 445 was put in
um after 9 11. yeah after 9 11.
um
and but so I think it's a good time to
you know we have some distance from what
happened and as I said I am not in this
taking a position on whether covet was
handled correctly I think this bill
should be supported even if you believe
the governor handled covet perfectly
because for one thing it is the
responsibility of the legislature to
when it's possible to weigh in on this
and second of all you never know what's
going to happen in the future and the
problem is you can say well it's a
hundred year event but the issue is once
you're in the emergency you can't do
anything about it if you you know you
have to think about it ahead of time and
make any adjustments to what should
happen during an emergency beforehand
representative Golan
thank you madam chair I will not be
supporting this we keep hearing over and
over about the legislative chair having
and let me just go on and read what's
current in statute as such time at such
joint session the legislature shall vote
on whether to terminate the state of
emergency by concurrent resolution
adopted by a simple majority of leave
both Chambers acting separately with the
following questions show the current
state of emergency be terminated
so I keep hearing over and over again
that the legislature needs to have input
I think what I just read states that the
legislature has input now
so I can't support it we already have it
in statute
we took a vote during the state of
emergency as the chair stated earlier it
failed
the opportunity is there this is not
needed
okay thank you representative Simon
finally and then thank you madam chair
um I guess I would just add to the
conversation that when these rules were
instituted back in 2011 after 9 11
the intent of uh yeah sorry 2001.
um the intent of them
was pretty well understood by the people
who put them into statute and when they
made those rules they did not have a
pandemic in mind
um as as a reason for why these
emergency Powers might be enacted we
still don't know the reasons all reasons
why an emergency a state of emergency
might be in enacted
um
it could be something that we're not
even thinking of right now the one main
difference between this bill and what is
currently in statute is that if the
legislative body for whatever reason
abdicates its responsibility
and doesn't show up to vote the state of
emergency continues whereas if the
legislature abdicates its responsibility
if 127 passes and doesn't show up to
vote the state of emergency ends
that is the main difference between what
is currently in statute and what 127 is
trying to accomplish and we should not
be abdicating our responsibility to show
up and take action the the governor has
to he has to call a joint session 90
days after that doesn't mean we have to
show up and vote and right now if we
don't show up and vote if there's not a
quorum then it just automatically
continues we we should have to show up
and act on that
and and give the people's opinion that's
just that's just my feeling on it
all right thank you
I'll rock some Gerhard
thank you madam chair I concur with
representative Simon that is more of an
opt-in than an opt-out kind of scenario
I think that's definitely necessary my
concern is that fear is the ultimate
controller of people and by instituting
a state emergency the governor is
basically implying that there's a
dangerous thing at at hand and we must
extend these powers that we would never
under normal circumstances extend to
them and I feel especially in the covet
situation if we want to talk about that
that has resulted in excessive
death and issues with the vaccine that
were pushed later on I think that's
important to remember so I don't even
want to start that ball rolling down the
hill ever again because I think it just
leads to more and more problems and
we're going to be seeing these for many
years to come so I will be supporting
this thank you representative goalie
thank you madam chair and I was
going to end it but I have to respond to
representative Simon because we were in
a pandemic that lasted longer than 90
days affected
many constituents across our state and
had deadly effects
that we all know about and to say we had
to meet with in 90 days
as a group to put this forward just to
continue it when we know at that point
public Gatherings were not acceptable at
the time
is the reason why we have in current
statute we have versus this thank you
okay
all right any more representative lekkis
uh thank you I just wanted to mention
that this legislature actually did meet
in less than 84 days even without this
uh this legislation in place and I agree
completely with representative Simon
there's a difference between the
legislature having the ability to act
and then having the duty to act the
requirement okay there's an assignment
now okay all right anyone else
all right seeing none
um
the motion is ought to pass on House
Bill 127 and the clerk can call the roll
representative Simon yes representative
lakis yes representative Bailey
yes
representative Santo nastasso yes
representative true
yes
representative Dolan yes
representative a bear yes
representative Gerhard
yes
the clerk votes yes representative
no representative Schmidt no
representative goalie no
representative O'Brien
no
representative Davis
representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative Gould
no
and the chair
yes
okay
the motion passes
and uh
yes
okay who will be writing it
okay so representative Broda will write
and
which is of course do uh no later than
tomorrow
representative blackis has the minority
right thank you that concludes that
all right and I'm opening the public
hearing on House Bill 339
I since it turned out to be much more
interesting to more people than I
imagined when I set this up I'm going to
ask you
based on the emails and calls I've
gotten not to concentrate on saying
Israel is wonderful or Israel is awful
because that's something that everybody
has probably made up their minds on so
we don't need to debate that here what
we need to discuss is what would the
effects of the bill be and why we want
to do it
um
I hope that it that it's not too much of
a problem and I will start with the
thank you madam chair
members of the committee thank you for
having me here today
um
for the record I am representative James
Spillane chairman of Fish and Game and
Marine Resources and I'm representing
Rockingham 2 and Deerfield candy in
Auburn
uh just to clear up a little
um
bookkeeping
first I'm gonna let you know that you
have the underlying bill you also have
an amendment that was delivered
yesterday and there's another amendment
pending now the Second Amendment is just
to add on
um the contracts portion And to clarify
what does it mean when we say boycott
Israel so it's got a preamble section
yep okay and I will give this passes
around to the committee and then I have
another amendment that I ask for coming
just because it was requested by legal
counsel that they that we include a
preamble of three legislative findings
at the beginning to establish
legislative intent if this ever gets
challenged so that's very simple it's
just a preamble those sometimes get cut
out anyway so it's not important to
really get into except that it does
State Legislative findings
so uh I bring before you a much needed
Bill HB 339 this bill will help defend
New Hampshire's economy and reinforce
our public policy through the
responsible spending and investing of
taxpayer funds all while placing only a
minimal administrative demand upon the
state
it's important for me to begin by
clarifying that HB 339's underlying
rationale is that the bill will create a
basic anti-discrimination law that
safeguards state funds from Investments
and contracts with problematic parties
who would otherwise undermine important
public policy protections upon which
many Granite Staters rely
as you know New Hampshire regulates
against many forms of discrimination and
has a duty to invest and spend States
funds consistently to that end
HB 339 keeps the threat of national
origin bias away from our state's
economy by defending our procurement and
investment processes from discriminatory
unethical and potent politically
motivated business partners
considering that most states have
already enacted laws with language
that's similar to HB 339 and I'll tell
you this 35 already
that have passed a bill identical to
this this is model legislation or a bill
that was a precursor to this when we
were still working out kinks in the
model legislation
passing this bill helps to ensure that
New Hampshire's conduct requirements for
State vendors are in line with common
national standards and thus uniform
HB 339 does not place any administrative
Duty upon the state to monitor the
marketplace activity
Contracting parties subject to the law
would only need to submit a basic
certification that they do not engage in
discriminatory commercial practices as
specified in the statute
the state's prohibited Investments list
will also only require minimal
Administration
to maintain it the officials only need
to undertake inquiries after being
notified of a particular case where
there's reason to believe the parties
may be participating in commercial
discrimination prohibited by the statute
so let me clarify what that's
essentially putting for a burden on the
state
you don't have to the state will not
need to continuously review nor
retroactively review current Investments
it's only going forward if somebody
brings forward a concern about an
investment that they're looking at doing
then the state would investigate it
so it would take
a party actually complaining that they
believe the company is involved in BDS
for the state to have to investigate
that
we're not telling the state to do these
investigations on everybody everything
and and those retroactive ones that have
been in place for years
35 states have already adopted these
anti-discrimination laws with
overwhelming success demonstrated in
their implementation and enforcement
the US government has emphatically
rejected boycotts based on national
origin and interferences with foreign
trade policy in general Congress has
legislated against boycotts of Israel
for four decades
and federal courts have ruled that
economic boycotts in general are not
protected free speech in particular the
export Administration Act of 1977 and
the ribikov amendment to the tax reform
Act of 1976 were both explicitly
designed to combat the Arab League's
boycott of Israel which extends to the
secondary and tertiary boycotts of firms
doing business with Israel
Federal Court decisions applying the
statutes have ruled that they do not
violate First Amendment because economic
boycotts are not protected speech but
are instead a form of commercial
activity
the United States government continues
to monitor these efforts through the
Department of Commerce office of
anti-boycott compliance which is the OAC
there's other countries that are also
oppose these boycotts of Israel and any
boycott in general of national origin
discrimination in October of 2015 the
Supreme Court of France ruled that the
BDS movement's actions demonstrate an
attempt to discriminate against a
particular country in this case Israel
the ruling was based on France's law
dealing with freedom of the press which
forbids discrimination hatred or
violence toward a person or group of
people grounds of their origin their
belonging or not belonging to an ethnic
group a nation a race or a certain
religion
in passing HB 339
you would demonstrate it's the New
Hampshire legislature's willingness to
forego business opportunities with
parties who's discriminatory commercial
practices make them otherwise unfit for
dealings with the state
and in exchange we Safeguard New
Hampshire's precious trade opportunities
with a country that's on The Cutting
Edge in every sector 85 companies listed
on the New York Stock Exchange and the
third highest number of companies listed
on the NASDAQ exchange after U.S and
China
the bill protects New Hampshire
companies from interference and
discriminatory boycotts as much as it
protects their Israeli trade partners
this bill's protecting New Hampshire's
right to free trade with Israel the
trade directly benefits our state's
entire economy and the quality of life
of all of our citizens
it encompasses many vital sectors Israel
is currently leading in Health Sciences
Agriculture and water
energy all areas of tech and research
and development and as of 2021 Israel
was the 14th biggest trading partner
with New Hampshire
the trade was valued in billions of
dollars
and with that I'm happy to answer any
questions although there are others
speaking behind me who may be better
suited to uh answer specifics yes I
think we will try to keep our questions
down
we've had similar bills so we should be
familiar with the concept
all right thank you representative
speline are there any questions
thank you madam chair good morning
colleagues my name is Jordan ullery of
Hillsboro 13 Hudson I'm Cedar and ways
and means in this house
it is my pleasure to speak on this
important bill regarding the need to
focus upon the revenues and our pension
systems some of you are aware patients
pension systems across the nature Nation
are in danger of collapse New Hampshire
is no exception
some of the reasons include the federal
government's Gatsby standards which
radically change changed our system from
pay as you go to pay into a fund first
that's oversimplified but it's a good
start to describe it another is
ill-advised can risky risky investment
in feel good or what I like to call
solyndra type Investments the latter is
rapidly developing into a source of
concern
as a fiduciary responsibility to the
employee seems to be being set aside in
favor of some very harmful Investments
or non-investments as a case may be
as one can see from the fiscal note
attached there is an indeterminable
effect upon this bill as it does not
prevent investment to accumulate Revenue
rather this bill prevents non-investment
divestiture or boycotting of Revenue
generation
that is abrogating the fiduciary
responsibility to fund things including
retire our retirement accounts even the
U.S Judiciary is noted that the primary
goal of investing by government in an
entity is a responsibility to the
recipients of the revenue it's not a
form of social action
BDS actions endanger the residents of
New Hampshire by unfairly and
deleteriously restricting the ability of
an investment to produce revenue for
investors
New Hampshire is the trading partner
with Israeli companies to the tune of as
was stated earlier but billions
some of this is in Joint Defense
Ventures some in education some in
Environmental Research some in medical
devices we see the benefits of this
Revenue generation when we did our
budget estimates
UNH and Dartmouth both receive hundreds
of thousands of dollars in educational
grants that provide for professors and
produce outstanding results in
agriculture or core research one only
needs to take a look at what has
happened in the Negev Desert to see how
the benefit of Agriculture takes place
several businesses such as but not
limited to Mill power L3 Communications
and over in Portsmouth sponged yet these
are direct recipients of the trade
relationship between Israel and New
Hampshire
a BDS scheme would put your neighbors
out of work quite literally in addition
there are hundreds of employees
available in Merrimack which works
closely with other defense Industries
small and large here in New Hampshire
elimination of jobs through a boycott
would reduce tax revenues to New
Hampshire through
reduced betbpt
and of course the secondary effect would
be people leaving New Hampshire so you'd
have the property taxes and then the
accumulation defect there
this bill protects New Hampshire
residents from the demonstrably bad and
risky even risky Investments directly
affecting our Pension funds and our
employees it is very likely
that the BDS and Investments run
contrary to both the New Hampshire and
the U.S constitutional restrictions on
discrimination
it is seemingly obvious that BDS
policies as a whole violated a host of
international treaties and Norms against
discrimination
this bill merely but clearly states that
one will not engage in systemic
discrimination rather that they must
focus on the fiduciary responsibility to
ensure the best possible return
and fund growth for our workers nothing
in the spilled demands investment in a
specific company nor companies from any
region in the world
neither does this bill prevent
investments in whatever company except
is specified this all this bill does is
clearly state that a systemic method of
discrimination is antithetical to the
principle of equal treatment and smacks
of the worst possible form of racism
racism namely government sanctioned
discrimination based upon race or Creed
or place of national origin
the investment fund is in Oregon is an
organ of state government and needs to
comply with both its fiscal
responsibilities and state law to ensure
the best possible Investments for our
pension fund for our state employees
that is why this bill is needed that is
why I support the effort
thank you for your attention oh answer
any questions
if you haven't are there uh specific
questions representative Gerhard thank
you madam chair
so receive some emails about this
legislation and one of them came from
the Rachel Corey foundation so she was
killed on March 16th in 2003 by in
Israel excuse me representative Gerhard
we are not going to debate whether
Israel is worthy we're going to
concentrate on the details of the bill
not no not about the situation of her
death but I'm addressing the email where
they're talking about this law being
struck down in Arizona it's pertinent
okay thank you I hope hope that is the
case Okay so she was killed in 2003 so
he formed a foundation and they write in
their letter that
in blocking Arizona's 2016 anti-boycott
law District Court Federal District
Court stated that a restriction of one's
ability to participate in Collective
calls to oppose Israel unquestionably
burden is the protected expression of
companies wishing to engage in such a
boycott the type of collective action
Collective action targeted by the
Arizona law specifically implicates the
rights of assembly and Association that
Americans and arizonans use to bring
about political social and economic
change has that been overruled or is
that still good law I mean that's
actually yes it was overturned to
representative but my comment on that
would be number one this is not the
Arizona law this is different than the
Arizona law number two fiduciary
responsibility is substantially separate
from social action if a company wants to
engage in Social actions they're
perfectly well capable of doing that on
their own
but they just can't
have as a policy of discrimination
against a specific individual they can
avoid they can say in their publication
we try not to but the primary goal has
got to be the fiscal responsibility that
they owe to their investors not to
a social action group that may or may
not have any responsibility to anyone
other than themselves
thank you thank you
all right thank you very much
representative uluri thank you man
thank you I'm going to be brief and for
the record I'm representative Judy Aaron
representative representing Sullivan
County District 4 which is Acworth
most of you know me as a staunch
supporter of Israel and a Jewish a
person of the Jewish faith
I come here today in opposition to this
bill
and it's not because I support any of
these companies that deal with BDS
activity
but I really truly believe that our
investment team here for our state
that political policy shouldn't be
interfering with their investment
strategies
our investment team should be using
investment criteria in order to be
making the decisions that they make on a
daily basis
if BDS supporting companies are a bad
investment
then they won't be investing in them and
for the most part I'm sure maybe these
companies are bad Investments
so I really think that while this bill
is well intentioned just as similar
bills have come before you with regard
to not investing in companies from China
um
I think that this is a well-intentioned
bill
but I don't think that it's something
that we should start going down that
road of dictating to our investment
teams
what they should and shouldn't invest in
and that's what I have to say today all
right thank you representative Aaron are
there questions
well I believe that was clear enough all
uh thank you madam chair uh I'm
representative Jess Edwards representing
Rockingham District 31.
um I uh I'm here in support of uh the
bill today I I'm a co-sponsor I have
four points I'd like to make and try to
keep it under four minutes
um first of all uh I you know I hope the
provisions should this bill pass into
law it's my hope that the provisions are
actually never needed or requiring to be
required to be enforced and uh and
that's because I think ultimately I
would want and wish for our invest our
investment Community to
do what it has done for a hundred years
and that is to put the priority of their
investments into their fiduciary
responsibility their fiduciary
responsibility is to the individual
investor they are supposed to make
decisions that maximize their return
when we're talking about the state
pension fund for example we need them to
make money so that we don't have to use
tax money to backfill any any loss so I
I want the focus to be on fiduciary
responsibility I I think that this bill
is asking for our society to be more
tolerant and more inclusive we have laws
all over our books that bar
discrimination this is another I think
in a long line of efforts for us to to
avoid explicit
discriminatory practices and this the
the Discrimination aspect here is pretty
obvious when people ask me what I think
about investing in companies with ESG
policies and why I might oppose them
while supporting this bill
simultaneously I I would say it's
because uh the the the principle the
theme Here is consistent is that we want
to have the people who make our
investment decisions be able to have the
flexibility to be inclusive and focused
on their fiduciary duty above sort of
I in my past was a product manager and I
worked for Eastman Kodak we had a
business partner in Rana Israel just
outside of Tel Aviv knit company named
alga Tech and alga Tech was a kind of a
premier tech technology company dealing
with medical imaging systems and
initially when I took that role I was
considered that a concerned that the
Middle East was kind of off limits to us
from a marketing perspective but I was
very happy to see over the years of in
that role that the um the many of the
Muslim nations had taken a look the
other way approach to the fact that we
marketed an Israeli product within our
our solution set and we closed an
enormous deal in Saudi Arabia with the
King Fahad hospital that required a lot
of cooperation in the sen of Israeli
Engineers to into Saudi Arabia to work
with with their counterparts and I found
that to be a very hopeful sign that our
global system of Commerce was actually
working to the benefit of mankind by
incentivizing a tolerance and acceptance
of others and I I I'm I'm not I so I'll
stop there and just say uh I I my
emphasis on this bill would would want
to be more positive than negative I
don't really like the fact that we're
saying we're prohibiting certain things
but I but I am very much in favor of us
encouraging certain socially redeemable
thank you madam chair for the record my
name is Marty Carlin representing the
New Hampshire retirement system uh nhrs
has not uh taken a formal position on
this bill uh our board has not weighed
in on it at this time uh provided uh
written testimony which is uh the same
as the testimony provided a few weeks
ago for House Bill 457 I'm not going to
waste your time by reading that today it
just it expresses a general concern
about any sort of legislation that would
um limit the investment Horizon of nhrs
in order to meet its fiduciary duty to
act in the best interests of members at
all times
um you know regardless of how
well-intentioned uh any piece of
legislation is
um
creating that precedent opens the door
for future
um
legislative enactments this is a purple
state things could you know we could be
looking at a bill in two to four years
about divesting from fossil fuels things
like that where you know anything that
that limits our investment folks ability
to
you know look at the landscape and try
to find you know the best return on our
assets for for the benefit of our
members a couple of the speakers Did
speak to fiduciary duty uh earlier and
um I will
reiterate there
um you know their statement that you
know our sole duty is to the membership
as fiduciary so the even the
undercurrent existing state and federal
law we don't see any
possibility or any any room for our
investment
committee or investment managers to put
other factors above
you know producing income so what I'm
saying is we you know we wouldn't you
know invest
um you know for purely social or
political gain already so I just wanted
to establish that as well and I'll be
oh thank you I think we remember the
last one
all right uh
thank you madam chairman members of the
committee my name is Craig Downing I'm
the executive director of the Deferred
Compensation Plan and commission which
oversees the plan it is a voluntary
supplemental retirement plan serving
state employees and members of 65
political subdivisions
um I wrote the fiscal note and uh I can
that's a the fiscal known as written and
explained uh I do agree
um there would be no cost
um other than the general you know we
have the same fiduciary rules as the
pension and any investment advisor we
have to choose by The Prudent investment
rule Investments for the sole benefit of
those members and their beneficiaries
again restrictions on that can place a
problem
the commission really doesn't get down
and do individual companies
but in a in a review of for this
legislation there's a there's a couple
companies in Europe that would fit the
bill
one of them is very large
and the companies I use here are
examples
um
and I'm I'm us I'm assured that it is in
an index so we have an index for
international funds there's Global funds
mutual funds which hold a variety of
Assets in and outside the country and
I'm sure this company is big enough to
be in there
my reading of the bill shows me that if
we have the Vanguard international Index
Fund
and it holds this company
that that is fine it is
my Marine and the bill is if the company
itself and just using the you know
company X in the United States
international fund
um if they
are against Israel then that would be a
problem
um I and then I'm relieved to know that
we we can't we don't have to go back
retroactively so that means that there
would be no changes of our current
Investments
in the plan
I'm happy to take questions
thank you
I think don't see any questions thank
you
yeah
Madam chair and committee members it's
an honor and a pleasure to be here and
to see so many friends my name is Paul
Birch I am a former State Rep I reside
in
Westmoreland New Hampshire
and I'm here on behalf of myself
which feels different I'd like to take a
few minutes just to talk about the legal
underpinnings of HB 339 and I had your
comment in mind and to clarify Beyond
reasonable question that this
legislation is fully constitutional is
not an impermissible infringement on the
First Amendment at the onset nothing I
say here should be construed as legal
advice that you have to pay for
the legality of this legislation is
based upon two core principles first
that HB 339 seeks to protect the
economic health of the State of New
Hampshire and its citizen investors and
two
that no company can force the state of
New Hampshire to act in a discriminatory
manner
both principles have been routinely
upheld by the courts up to and including
the Supreme Court
economic expression
economic conduct is not expression and
the fact that it may have political
motivation doesn't make it expression
that's why states can and often do ban
refusals to do business solely because
of an individual's race national origin
religious affiliation or other status
even if accompanied by speech
this is fundamental to our
anti-discrimination laws again acts may
have a political motivation but that
doesn't necessarily protect those Acts
and to be clear this proposed Bill only
covers economic conduct does not
regulate speech of any kind
parties who contract with the state
remain free to express any view they
please about Israel or any other topic
so let me give you a few examples of the
interaction perhaps of politics and uh
and other factors I saw a case the other
day where a person was arrested for
blocking traffic and this person was
holding a political sign
and she said well this is my First
Amendment right to express my opinion
and as the courts determine it's not
protected as the state has a strong
reason to keep the road safe
you may support Russia in the Russia
Ukrainian War
but you can't send military stuff to
Russia and claim it's protected by your
First Amendment right
we hear around here from time to time
that the phrase taxation is theft
but failure to pay your taxes
is not protected by claiming the First
Amendment still have to pay your taxes
whether you take a political stand
against taxation or not
the case Rumsfeld V Fair
and this had to do with under a federal
law Banning College recruiters military
Recruiters on campus
and it was said well they're banning
them is expressing a First Amendment
right
and the U.S Supreme Court said no
because it's not inherently expressive
so I'm going to go back one more case
way back when some of you or possibly of
an age to remember uh when draft cards
were burned
and certainly was said
I probably said it that burning the
draft card is a politically
expressive act protected by the First
Amendment
and they went up to the Supreme Court
U.S versus O'Brien and it set up a
four-part test and I think this K this
bill fills all four parts of the
so-called O'Brien test
is it within the Constitutional power of
the government if the government
regulation first is it it's Justified if
it's within the Constitutional power of
the government yes it furthers an
important or substantial government
interest yes the interests of the
government is unrelated to the
suppression of free expression and the
incidental restriction on free
expression is no greater than necessary
to the furtherance of the government
effort all of these are checked off in
HB 339
note the companies can say what they
want they can petition Lobby carry signs
they can participate in a boycott
themselves if it's otherwise legal but
it can't force the state of New
Hampshire to abandon its
anti-discrimination policy or its policy
to invest only in safe and prudent
Investments
you may hear at some point I'm not sure
who else is going to speak about a
Clairborne Hardware case dealing with
boycotts based on racial discrimination
the Supreme Court affirmed that rights
to speak petition and assemble are
protected by the First Amendment but it
did not create a right to economically
discriminate whenever the discriminator
has a political motive in another case
decided around the same time the
international longshoreman's Case held
at a prohibitional secondary boycotts
could apply to politically motivated
boycotts a secondary boycott or they're
intended to pressure
the Target and deceasing to do business
with a third party
I'm going to close
basically with a case that's higher up
than the
Arizona case it's the the recent
Arkansas times case just looked at by
the U.S Supreme Court it's right now the
highest Authority in the United States
it's the uh only federal circuit court
of appeals to rule and which the Supreme
Court only a week or so ago unanimously
it seems refused to consider overturning
and this is the quote
the legislative legislature's motive for
passing acts 7 10 was primarily economic
it repeatedly expressed concern for the
commercial viability of companies that
refused to do business with Israel and
the effect this could have on the
state's finances
for example section blabla points out
that companies that make discriminatory
decisions on the basis of national
origin and pair their commercial
soundness
another section says these companies are
unduly risky Contracting Partners or
vehicles for investment because they
don't have access to Israeli Innovations
we've heard about some of that already
these findings suggest suggest a purely
commercial purpose for the statute and
waste ways strongly in favor of
upholding the statute the statute
prohibits purely commercial
non-expressive conduct it has not been
Arkansas at times from publicly
criticizing Israel or even protesting
the statute itself it only prohibits
economic decisions that discriminate
against Israel
finally the single leading academic
study on this subject written by Josh
Halpern a researcher at Harvard just
came out about a week ago actually I
read a 44-page working paper shows that
states have been regulating boycotts for
centuries this bill is consistent with
the nation's history
a tradition of boycott regulations does
not offend the First Amendment thank you
all right seeing none
yes representative Schmidt
goodbye
oh absolutely I'll hand this right over
right representative blackis you have a
question
okay other than that I'd like to say
it's good to see representative Burch
again
indeed
foreign
my name is Scott Dickman I live right
here in Concord New Hampshire
Madam chair firstly I thank you uh each
and every one of you
uh for providing an opportunity to
address this committee a model of
democracy at work
where disagreements about proposed
legislation can all be heard and debated
for this precise reason I stand before
you today or I sit before you today as a
Jew who in 1973 upon the outbreak of War
called the Israeli Embassy in New York
City to volunteer
blown into Israel by the government with
several other volunteers
um
I lived there for several years
motivated by a protective love for that
country
and I tell you this to negate the
proposition that individuals opposed to
this legislation are anti-Semitic
any such suggestion is is at the very
least deceitful
and used to avoid any discussion of
Israel of Israeli policies towards
Palestinians
I personally oppose BDS
yet I ask that you defend free speech of
all Americans by opposing any effort to
pass deeply misguided legislation that
undermines the very same core principle
of American democracy on display at
today's hearing
I firmly believe that that legislating
against boycotts which are a form of
speech protected under the First
Amendment opens the door to much broader
government control of public discourse
wouldn't we reject this framework in any
other context
so too then in the fight against all
forms of anti-semitism
we must uphold our most fundamental
Democratic principles
while proponents of legislative
penalties on BDS supporters portray the
reference as pro-israel the proposed
legislation will have no impact on
bringing about a peace agreement or even
wiping out anti-semitism
namely working toward a two-state
solution
and a long-term person peace agreement
that creates a better future for both
Israelis and Palestinians
this objective can only materialize
through debate and negotiation
in conclusion I ask you to to oppose any
legislation that speaks that seeks to
buy to silence or suppress free speech
and non-violent activism a repeat
um as isn't that the Holy Grail of
American democracy
negating free speech is the least
constructive Avenue towards a negotiated
solution to this or any conflict
um
and I have to add listening to some of
the prior testimony that
um I I've heard reference to the
anti-discriminate discriminatory
benefits that this legislation
carries in its toe
um and I and I find that
um difficult to digest
um
and I think the legislation is flawed
for this reason there there is BDS
um and then there is something referred
to as limited BDS which refers only to
the boycott of of goods and services in
the occupied territories the occupied
territories
um violate international law
and that's been well established by the
United Nations
um could you please focus on the bill I
appreciate the the history lesson but
and I apologize for that background but
hearing is the distinction that that
pertains directly to the bill
um
the uh
the suggestion that BDS
that
opposing BDS is
um
is to preserve non-describe
non-discrimination
um violates the notion that that there
that there is unfortunately the
political underpinnings of this
um which can't be negated
um there there is a BDS limited BDS
which seeks to oppose
Commerce with the occupied territories
which violate international law okay
thank you very much and so I would ask
that the legislation at the very least
be amended to
um
to oppose BDS
only in regard to the territory within
the national
um the fines of Israeli territory which
is
to the west of the green line thank you
very much all right
hi
you'll have to speak into the microphone
please
can you hear me now okay my name is
Cheryl LeBron and I'm representing
myself in the organization in New
Hampshire called New Hampshire for
Israel
um what the BDS movements leaders have
um please do concentrate on the bill and
okay
it should be noted that the top level
leadership of the BDS movement includes
the U.S designated terror group Hamas
Palestinian Islamic Jihad and pflp which
stands for the popular front for the
liberation of Palestine
these organizations use Western civil
Civil Society organizations to pursue to
pursue their goal of destroying the
state of Israel
the BDS hate movement uses false claims
packaging nicely and human right lingo
to demonize Israel and promote
anti-Semitism in order to isolate the
Jewish state from its friends and allies
the rhetoric of the BDS movement
uses has been condemned as anti-semitic
by both chambers of the U.S legislative
the U.S presidents from both parties in
the Secretary General of the U.N
the true aims of the BDS help move hate
movement become clear when you listen to
the movement's leader in their own words
number one
this is by Ahmed Moore pro-bds author
and in the occupation doesn't mean
anything if it doesn't mean upending the
Jewish State itself BDS does mean the
end of the Jewish State excellent thank
you we we get that point what else do
you have that's relevant to the bill in
question
I think the BDS movement will gain
strength from forthrightly explaining
why Israel has no right to Exist by John
pritzer
thank you very much
honorable members of the House of
Representatives thank you for having me
it's my first time speaking at the
government building so I apologize if I
stutter I'm a little bit nervous
my name is abdullatif I am a resident of
Lebanon New Hampshire
I am an ethnically jewish practitioner
of the Muslim faith
so when I hear that BDS discriminatory
or criticism of the state of Israel is
somehow discriminatory or identity based
or anti-semitic it very often feels like
a denial of my own existence I just want
to put that out there frankly when it
comes to this bill I'm a little bit
confused
uh there is a desire to stop to not
invest in people that are boycotting the
state of Israel to in fact boycott
against people who are boycotting the
state of Israel that is quite
paradoxical it is quite confusing it
feels quite discriminatory frankly if
there's a Palestinian family business
that they don't want to invest in Israel
for their own family reasons and we will
not invest in them as a state because of
this that seems incredibly incredibly
discriminatory and we've heard a lot of
legalese about why you know economic
actions are not Free Speech but frankly
this is New Hampshire our state motto is
Live Free or Die uh it does feel like it
is somehow or the other for particular
reasons to protect to stop a particular
type of political action we have argued
that somehow this economic action is not
free speech when in fact in the
colloquial sense in the day-to-day sense
how I spend my money is my business it
is free speech and if someone chooses
not to again there's inaction that's
taking place a lot of the examples that
the former rep spoke again very
eloquently about were actions of action
giving military weapons to Russia is if
actual action it's a positive out you're
doing something to not invest to not
give money to not do something like this
is quite the opposite I really find it
to not be comparable
and and finally you just want to make
this very clear this is again making
something people's private action it's
making a humanitarian issue a political
issue somehow inaccessible stopping
people from expressing themselves from
giving some sort of criticism
uh and I really hope that the New
Hampshire
House of Representatives does not follow
these other states who I believe are
frankly making a mistake the fact that
many people are doing something does not
make it right we have to stand for what
is actually right for what is actually
just and also financially I yes Israel
has done amazing Innovations you know
ways Etc other apps there are a lot of
other countries that are doing a lot of
financial things I think a particular
company not investing in them
they may have other Investments it
doesn't seem like it's a financially
foolish decision as has been claimed
many many a Time thank you for your time
and sorry if I spoke too fast well
that's fine
we can listen fast
thank you uh Madam chairwoman committee
my name is Jake Bennett I'm here on
behalf of the Israeli American Coalition
for Action non-profit yes sir
yes there you go
all right my name is Jake Bennett I'm
here on behalf of the Israeli American
Coalition for Action a non-profit that
represents Israelis and their families
who've made their home in America
today is a Jewish holiday it's shushan
Purim the second day of the holiday of
Purim which remembers a series of events
in Persia 2300 years ago when a man
named Haman plotted to slaughter
Persia's Jews but in the end was
thwarted through the intercession of
Queen Esther in an act of the king
today's A fitting day to pass an
anti-bds Bill through Committee in New
Hampshire
um
I had some testimony a lot of my topics
were covered already I'd like to cover a
couple of points that were that were
brought up to keep it brief
to rep gerhard's question about about
the Arizona law it was never struck down
there was an injunction putting it on
hold while it was looked at same with a
few of the other states but in no state
was it stuck down struck down and in
every state where it was challenged
those laws are still in place and were
found constitutional as uh discussed in
detail by representative Birch
um
one of the the topics that's been raised
in the question asked is um is is how is
this uh how is this bill
to be understood as anti-discrimination
I would say there's an analogy to be
looked at just in in contracts and the
way contracts are done there are
affirmations of non-discrimination that
companies make in order to be eligible
for a state contract
a couple of people said
well if you uh if you were to not invest
in a company that's boycotting Israel
you're limiting your investment Universe
I'd say you might make the same argument
if you
um if you won't contract with a company
that says they discriminate on the basis
of race or sex or national origin you're
limiting your Contracting universe but
the state has said repeatedly we have an
obligation to our citizens uh to not
engage in discrimination and and it's in
that same vein that that uh that this
law is put forward
um
there was uh there was a topic raised um
by uh by a gentleman who spoke about
limited BDS also known as territories
only BDS
um American law U.S federal law and the
2015 TPO treats Israel as an economic
monolith so that means you can't
differentiate and the fact is as we saw
in the case of Unilever when they said
we're going to do a territories only uh
boycott uh similarly when Airbnb in 2019
said we're going to do a territories
only boycott against Jews and only allow
Arabs to list their homes for vacation
rental but nachos this went against
American Trade policy
because the fact is Israel is a small
state it's about the size of New
Hampshire it's 10 000 square miles and
the country uh in addition to its own
laws
not allowing discrimination based on
based on place or based on on
nationality
um it's one small economy so the banks
are the banks everywhere both in the
liberated part of of the old city of
Jerusalem and in the uh the pre-48 uh
side of Jerusalem
um
likewise the same gas stations serve all
over the same Telecom company when you
get your your cell phone there's no way
to break up Israel and also
from a moral perspective uh
discrimination against a Jew for living
in the biblical Heartland
is as egregious as as uh discriminating
against one who who lives in Tel Aviv
um and another comment that was made
that it's against uh international law
well U.S policy is that it is not
illegal for Jews to live in the biblical
Heartland of Judea and Samaria and this
is in keeping with a uh with a U.S law
passed through Congress in 1924 that
recognized the League of Nations mandate
for the creation of a Jewish state in
those lands which was never abrogated so
the fact that all the Jews were kicked
out in 48 by the jordanians from those
Highlands of Judea and Samaria and then
returned after 67
that expulsion never made it uh a legal
thing in international law excuse me
please don't debate the other test
testifiers let's just talk about the
Bill yes ma'am
um I would say uh one one more analogy
for for for those who find it hard to
understand what BDS has to do with
discrimination if a chinese-american
were boycotted because of someone's
hatred for China or China's policies it
would be readily understood as an act of
racist or national origin based
discrimination
similarly when people boycott not only
the BDS movement boycotts not only
Israel and Israeli companies but also uh
Israeli American-owned companies Jewish
companies and those who do business with
them uh the analogy should be clear
so
I think that'll do it if there's any
questions I'm happy to address them
yes
thank you madam chair I just want to
clarify I did look that case up and it
turns out the guy had an 18. please
please we don't want to debate case law
no I don't want to debate I just want to
clarify that so he had a contract for
eighteen thousand dollars the
legislature changed the law to make it a
hundred thousand dollars or greater or
ten or more employees so it was deemed
moot it wasn't overturned I just wanted
yes that's correct it was the movie and
the legislature issued a statement at
the time they said we want to make it
very clear that we don't want to impede
anyone's uh anyone's First Amendment
rights and in the case of an independent
uh proprietor sole proprietor business
there could be some gray area or
murkiness so let's make it clear and so
they said exactly those changes he did
you'll have to spell your name I'm
r-a-m-s-e-y-l-a-l-s-h-e-i-k-h I am a
Dartmouth student
um I do a lot of things on campus over
for the newspaper for one I just
published an article saying uh why this
bill has several problems I'm very
concerned about personally uh number one
being
um probably it's unconstitutionality we
live in a state uh whose motto is Live
Free or Die uh if I remember correctly
it's not live for Israel or die it's
about American citizens and their rights
as guaranteed in the Constitution
contrary to what some um some words that
haven't spoken here a boycotting is a
valid form of political expression if
it's being used to that and not to
benefit any economic actors there are
several presidents for this such as
anti-racist boycotts in America Martin
Luther King South Africa boycotting has
been a very well established technique
to voice political dissent and it's a
protected technique as many legal cases
have ruled uh specifically as regards to
BDS if you want to go there there have
been Federal cases in Arkansas Kansas
Georgia and Texas I've upheld the right
of uh BDS you know boycotters to use
their their right to express themselves
politically through boycotts
um this is to me a very clearly a bill
that seeks to limit that right or at
least to try and coerce people not to
use that right by withholding funds from
companies that choose to exercise that
right it's an attempt to Blacklist
companies which voice their political
Expressions I mean we can get into the
all the legalese about that um I have
finals to study for so I'm not going to
go review all of the case law for that
but to me it's a very clear-cut uh
instance of constitutional right it's
not about anything other than that to me
the idea that somehow this is related to
discrimination is uh quite odd for me
personally uh considering that I don't
see a single person of you know color in
this room and I think that
um you know criticizing a state for its
policies which have been condemned by
international human rights organizations
is not discrimination in fact that seems
to me like very valid criticism and I
think any company which chooses to
protecting that for whatever reason
should have that right guaranteed
um the idea that this is somehow an
issue of discrimination doesn't make
sense to me also because there are many
uh Jewish organizations in America which
support BDS for example Jewish voice for
peace many individuals I've talked to in
my life who have supported BDS although
it's not the normal position there are
many Jewish folks who do support that
and I think kind of trying to paint it
like every Jew is somehow opposed to BDS
is we've already heard that well we did
hear that and I stand for that so for me
this is a very clear instance of
violating a First Amendment writes this
is I can go into a whole moral issues
with this bill considering what's going
on please don't Israel Palestine right
now I will not but
on the whole I think this is a very
serious matter uh regarding
constitutionality if there's any
questions I'd love to take them thank
you very much we appreciate appreciate
your all
ah yes
how tall are you
um representative here about that's a
personal question
he's taller than I am I'm sure okay all
right
all right thank you thank you very much
for your testimony thank you very much
thank you for all having me here Madam
chairwoman the rest of the committee
represent Gerhart I'm six foot one by
the way not two yet six foot two but a
little bit about that
so I'm here representing the Israeli
American Council of New England and
because of that I'm here representing uh
the private businesses of some Israeli
citizens right here in New Hampshire
from as small as five to as many as more
than 1500 people the BDS movement seeks
to delegitimize and isolate Israel by
boycotting Israeli products and
companies this has a direct impact on
israeli-owned businesses causing harm to
their employees and their ability to
operate BDS campaigns often Target small
and medium-sized Israeli businesses that
rely on exports including to places like
right here in New Hampshire to sustain
their operations these businesses are
often run by ordinary Israelis who are
just trying to make a living and
contribute to their economy the BDS
movement's actions also harm
Palestinians who work in israeli-owned
businesses and rely on them for their
livelihoods by targeting Israeli
businesses the BDS movements putting the
jobs in livelihoods of many Palestinians
at risk the BDS movement's targeting of
Israeli businesses based on their
nationality is discriminatory and goes
against the principle bowls of Freedom
democracy and human rights it is unfair
to punish individuals and businesses
based on their nationality and is
reminiscent of historical discrimination
against Jews I will move on to New
Hampshire sorry about that Madam please
yes absolutely so directly to New
Hampshire BDS discourages economic
investment in New Hampshire by Israeli
companies and Israel Israel and
specifically Tel Aviv is the fastest
growing high-tech sector in the world
BDS encourages divestment from New
Hampshire companies that do business
with Israel BDS can lead to a reduction
in exports from New Hampshire to Israel
and other countries due to those
boycotts BDS May discourage tourism to
New Hampshire from countries that merely
support the boycott of Israel BDS harms
the ability of New Hampshire to attract
talented workers from Israel and other
countries yes
uh excellent how does this apply to us
Banning the Banning the retirement
system from investing in these companies
from Banning the excuse me from
investing in companies that are believed
to be involved in these activities yes
because if somebody is a supporter of
BDS and that goes into the law then New
Hampshire is not going to have as
vibrant of an economy if those are if
those companies are boycotted so when it
comes to the issue of boycott divestment
and sanction of Israel Israeli companies
and israeli-owned companies right here
in New Hampshire with the inclusion of
BDS you will see a decrease in
investment to New Hampshire not just in
terms of the economy itself but also in
terms of Tourism and simply creating
businesses right here in New Hampshire
but to go on specifically to the
economic harm the BDS movement targets
israeli-owned businesses which as I
mentioned could harm the economic
interest of our members who own or work
for such businesses the social exclusion
many others have talked about it the
intimidation tactics the BDS movement
uses tactics and this is specific to the
small businesses here in New Hampshire
but is something I believe must be said
yep
the question is not on whether we should
be encouraging small businesses in New
Hampshire it's should we forbid our
retirement system to make certain for
making certain Investments yes and when
it comes to that you don't want to limit
any of the Investments with BDS you are
going to be limiting the Investments
investments in Israeli companies
investments in the Israeli economy as we
mentioned yes but I don't believe I
don't believe anyone has said our
correct correct yes thank you okay good
okay
I apologize
um so just finally overall the BDS
movement has the potential to negatively
impact the economic social and political
interests of New Hampshire members who
are Israeli Americans and for that
reason I
oppose oh sorry I'm for this Bill thank
you all for your time thank you very
much
representative Gould
very quick thank you for describing what
boycott divest and sanction is thank you
yeah I actually made it a point I
realized everybody's been saying BDS so
just again for the record boycott
divestment and sanction from Israel okay
thank you appreciate the number thank
you all
all right
good afternoon members of the committee
and Madam chair my name is Hayden Smith
and I'm from Hanover I'm here today on
behalf of New Hampshire youth movement
to speak in opposition to HB 339
our movement is a signatory on a
statement signed by nine other pro-piece
pro-human rights solidarity
organizations in New Hampshire that
oppose this bill
I mailed a full copy to this of this
statement to the committee last night
but if you didn't have a chance to read
it I have a copy right here my printer
was broken so sorry I don't have one for
everyone but if you'd like a photocopy
I'd be happy to give it over thank you
we will take one for the file and we did
get that email excellent
um but I would like to use my time today
to speak a bit more succinctly to our
reasons and I'll keep focused on this
bill
out of respect for what you've said we
believe that this bill sends an alarming
message that would limit the ability to
boycott in New Hampshire
boycotts are an effective form of a
non-violent protest that has been used
to protest for to protest civil and
human rights abuses in multiple contexts
ranging from the time of the American
Revolution to the Civil Rights Movement
in a more International context you
might also be more familiar with
boycott's protesting the apartheid
regime in South Africa only a few
decades ago today some individuals and
businesses do employ boycotts to
peacefully protest against the Israeli
government's involvement
anti-palestinian violence and I'd like
to emphasize against the actions the
government actions of the Israeli
government not against Israelis for
being Israelis
um
unfortunately this is not stepped
several States from attempting to
restrict the right to boycott
similar and perhaps even harsher
restrictions than this bill have already
been implemented in several other states
and or are still being debated you might
be familiar with some examples in
Arkansas lately
while we acknowledge that HB 339 would
not officially ban companies in New
Hampshire from taking part in a boycott
we want to emphasize this measure which
still represents a blacklist
by blocking the investment of State
funds
this measure still represents the
government penalty for companies that
hold a certain opinion about
International Affairs and participate in
a legitimate form of peaceful protest
we believe this constitutes an
inappropriate form of State interference
regardless of where you feel it falls on
the First Amendment
if passed it would also carry the
implica this bill would also carry the
implication that New Hampshire is taking
a stand on the israeli-palestinian
conflicts we know that's still a highly
controversial topic to discuss but we
feel that it would be inappropriate for
New Hampshire to be weighing in in this
manner even by passing a slot is still
picking aside
we're not asking the general court to
officially weigh in on the conflict but
we do ask the legislature refrain from
an inflicting punishment from boycotts
and other legitimate forms of protest
and
um with that I urge you to report HP 339
as inexpedient to legislate thank you
for your time and I'm happy to take any
questions
I didn't see any questions Jeffrey
saloway
thank you madam chairman members of the
committee
for the record
um I am Jeffrey Coleman salloway I was a
three-term representative from Lee New
Hampshire and mercifully was able to
escape
um I am professor emeritus from the
University of New Hampshire and in half
a century of the of being a professor I
learned two things number one when the
discussion goes past lunchtime you lose
your audience
number two if you hand out your notes
even though you've lost the attention of
your audience because we're past
lunchtime they will have something to
take with them that will remind them my
concerns are regarding the impact of BDS
activity uh on my former constituents in
New Hampshire I have just a few brief
examples to give you and then a brief
conclusion
um there is a disease called
glioblastoma it is a form of cancer it
affects the brain it is left untreated
invariably fatal there is an Israeli
invention it is an electric hat if you
will a cap
which
is a fairly successful treatment for
glioblastoma it's sold by novocure which
is headquartered in Portsmouth New
Hampshire behind the Market Basket on
Woodbury Avenue no
yes sir I we we have your notes and what
does we understand that investing in
Israel might be a great idea what do you
want to talk about the bill
I want to talk about my students whose
staff novocure jobs for my UNH graduates
we have sambucus a treatment for viral
diseases that came to this country
through one of my constituents
um ronstock at herbal Pathways in Dover
and Portsmouth we have GPS mapping which
is on your cell phone as Waze as Google
Maps and as TomTom Tom Tom is located in
Lebanon New Hampshire just behind the
Lebanon Shopping Center in the river
valley Club it's a big win for employees
in the Upper Valley we have baa systems
in Nashua a big win for American defense
we have Sig Sauer in Newington Epping
led by an Israeli it's a big win for
Seacoast jobs okay and what what do
these excellent companies have to do
with we deny no one the right to make
individual choices for their personal
lives but as New Hampshire we have the
right to prevent those with specific
political agendas from limiting
legitimate economic activity which
advances the common good in New
Hampshire we play games where everyone
can access the big win these have been
big wins for us there are no losers with
BDS my colleagues everyone loses
if there are any questions I'd be glad
to take them and then I hope we can
break for lunch
thank you very much for for hearing us
uh today my name is Ken kowalczyk I'm
retired from the uh from a career in
Foreign Service uh at the state
department and uh now living in Hampton
New Hampshire I'm a member of New
Hampshire for Israel and a proud Jew uh
one of the things that I would
and
talking about today is my time in
Rwanda in 1993 and 1994. I was the
administrative officer there and could
you please explain how that has to do
something with this bill it has to do
with the D and BDS I suggest to you that
the D is demonization demonization of
one people to another I know exactly
what that can lead to and
this is the the real issue that we have
to face when we're looking at
boycott demonization and sanctions and
uh you know I have a prepared statement
which I will give to the people talking
about this it the fact that
anti-zionism is now the new
anti-semitism
so uh
there's a lot of anti-israel rhetoric of
the BDS hate movement and where does all
this anti-zion and Zionism lead last
week
a New York federal court sent in the
sentencing hearing of Masood a man of a
violent
convicted of violently attacking Jews in
New York City in at least three
occasions proved once again that some
anti-zionism is really nothing more than
anti-Semitism his attorneys actually
argued that his case of assault of
innocent American Jewish people
was because he is in anti-semite but no
it was rather he was seeking to promote
social and political goals and that he
resorted to violence because he felt so
deeply about the occupation of Palestine
in defiling the prosecutor showed the
court the defendant's messages
okay I I'm I'm we have gone a great deal
longer than I expected and I really I I
understand I would like to then I'll I
only have one copy unfortunately with
that gentleman but I I do want to
um uh close in in saying that when a uh
a car Rams a bus stop full of
men women and children in Tel Aviv or
Jerusalem and another car
Ram's a group of men women and children
in Charlottesville
saying Jews will not replace us both
incidents are really identical they're
they're quite the same
so remember that when you vote on bdns
we should have nothing to do with B D
and S this group us as New Hampshire
citizens and this legislature thank you
Matt
thank you very much
all right good afternoon everyone Madam
chairman and members of the committee my
name is Matt saborn D schwannier I would
spell it please for our Clerk
all right here we go
to the map we can get capital s a b o u
r i n space lowercase d-i-t capital
c-h-o-n-i-e-r-e
laughs thank you no wonder I couldn't
and five foot seven and a half
cool so uh
testifying opposition this legislation
today I'm a American Veteran a former
Air Force Captain deployed to Kuwait for
a little bit spent 12 days in Iraq as
well my diplomacy for six months in
sports Isis campaign
I'm also a member of the USS Liberty
veterans association as well New
Hampshire should not be punishing
Granite State businesses for the
position on Israel there's a good few
reasons to boycott them the USS Liberty
was an American spy ship that was
attacked by the state of Israel on June
8 1967 by the New England Air Forces of
the state of Israel of a crew of 294
officers and Men including three
civilians
rate on the bill rather than on the
history lessons that are no doubt
fascinating perfect yes ma'am so this
particular incident was never
investigated by the D.C government the
center for legislative archives has now
has no files in the records of House and
Senate committees related to an
investigation of the 1967 USS Liberty
and Vincent incident the only individual
who was ever punished from that event
was the fighter pilot who did not comply
with the order to attack
many American politicians will describe
the relationship between American Israel
as our greatest Ally with an unbreakable
friendship just watch any video of
Donald Trump or Nancy Pelosi speaking at
the American Israeli public affairs
committee it's unacceptable given the
status of this uninvestigated incident
in our more recent Middle East foreign
policy the state of New Hampshire should
not be punishing granted State
businesses for the position on Israel
that's their decision to make instead
the state of New Hampshire should be
pressuring the D.C government to conduct
a proper investigation of the USS
Liberty incident and provide a
restitution to its victims
thank you madam chair I had this is a
yes or no do you support 339
House Bill 339 uh opposition to it
thank you very much I gotta go to work
I'll see you guys later as well
I'm John LeBrun from Loudon New
Hampshire I'm here to support uh House
Bill 339
uh I want to thank the committee for
taking letting us speak I support House
Bill 339 prohibiting the investment of
State funds in any company participating
in the boycott of Israel the modern
state of Israel was founded in 1948.
Israel is the only democratically run
country in the Middle East all Israelis
participate in free elections enjoy
freedom of speech religious freedom and
have the right to a trial investing in
companies that participate in a boycott
of Israel harms the economy of Israel
and other countries and states too many
useful items are invented or improved
upon in Israel such as the cell phone
USB drive Intel dual core processor drip
irrigation top multiple sclerosis drugs
therapeutic disease treatments for
Parkinson's Disease and I could go on
and on third Israel is one of the first
countries to respond to natural
disasters anywhere in the world refugees
for the war in Ukraine have been
welcomed into Israel
Israel is also a leader environmental
sustainability and lots of water
conservation every United States
President sits Truman has aborted Israel
in some form in September in 2020
several Middle East countries were
formerly not friendly to Israel sign an
agreement to normalize relations this
agreement called the Abraham Accords was
signed in Washington D.C president Trump
assisted the signing process which
concluded Israel United Arab Emirates
Bahrain Morocco and later Sudan also
enjoyed enjoying the agreement
negotiations are ongoing to include more
nations in conclusion I hope you agree
me that passing HB 339 is the right
thing to do and I thank the committee
is there anyone else that needs to
testify on House Bill 339
okay so I'm going to close the public
hearing
and we the executive session will will
be delayed a bit until
145.
dual Republicans plea Republicans please
be back by 1 30 so we can have a brief
caucus
foreign
all right everybody welcome back thank
you for uh
for being here
for
let's see where's my list oh there it is
all right for everyone's information
House Bill
457 and 559
will not be voted on today because the
subcommittee is meeting on Friday we
will be executing them on Friday Also
um
probably about 1 32 o'clock before our
scheduled meeting on House Bill 2.
the exec is not in the calendar because
I have to announce it from the house
floor
um
and I would also like to mention that
next Wednesday we have
a few hearings on bills that I expect
who will be able to vote on that day
and I'm hoping not to have to come back
for anything on them
so
uh 457 and 559
they're both in the pension subcommittee
which is meeting Friday
all right so
um
let's
I'm sure he is
oh no he stepped out for a minute he's
probably in the men's room he'll be here
we haven't lost him yet there he is
okay so
um
we'll we'll start with with uh one of
the bills we heard today House Bill 84
which is the Emergency Management powers
of the Department of Transportation does
someone have a motion
representative a bear
thank you madam chair
I have a motion to itls
well I'm glad to hear you've got support
okay do you wish to speak to your motion
representative Amir
thank you madam chair I do wish to speak
to my motion and thank you
representative
Schmidt for your comments and
excuse me as the testimony that we heard
mainly from dot is that we already have
a lot in place that we are not
necessarily building underneath us or
holding the accountability or
strengthening to take over this piece of
of uh what we're looking for in this
legislation and therefore I don't think
this is necessary at this time thank you
representative Schmidt
thank you madam chair and thank you
representative for your motion uh the
thing is that we all understand that the
situation in Acworth was indeed tragic
and catastrophic in that particular
occasion
but this is a kind of in a sense a
perfect storm or uh and therefore
there's no way that it's possible for
the D.O.T under the circumstances to be
immediately on the spot if you live
right next to the fire station or the
police station maybe you'll get instant
service on a call but this was the kind
of situation where they needed help in
all areas could not be done uh and the
statute is already in place
organizations already in place they
maybe need to perfect it a little bit
but it doesn't need legislation all
right thank you does anyone else have a
comment
oh
I don't think so representative shewitt
thank you madam chair
um I'll just add that uh the comment was
made about
um
having a public works Mutual Aid setup
and then the comment was also added that
there were questions about who would get
paid how if another Town Sent their
Public Works employees and this bill
doesn't address that kind of situation
at all so I think going forward as
something like this is put forward that
type of issue needs to be addressed also
um well I heard that there is a public
works Mutual Aid Society and it was
ineffective in this case because all the
towns around were suffering
so hey
am I not representative O'Brien thank
you madam chair
um in the audience today was a former
Fire Chief from Hudson
Robbie Buxton who now is a Homeland
Security and something like this in the
future I you know let's we can't dwell
upon the past but let's look at the
future and I did it was able to have a
brief conversation with him and although
I am sympathetic to representative
Aaron's plea with this uh I don't think
what had happened in the past would
happen today you know so uh
what happens it seems to be the fault of
the incident command system and the
whole thing in general if we have people
at the state level that are willing to
uh Supply this uh resource because
that's what it's there for these things
can quickly get out of control over the
capabilities of your average police
chief or fire chief you need to help and
that's where the state will come in and
to rely on resources through delegation
so I think as we move forward that would
occur and also too uh sadly I do
recommend that the good people of that
Community join them mutually Compact and
to help out that would go a long way
into assist but like you say it's
regional when something like this
happens it can infect globally other
communities right next door to yourself
I'll leave it at that thank you madam
chair representative Gould
thank you madam chair living in a small
community and representing people in
small towns I really appreciate the need
for this and I was very very encouraged
by Dot's statement that they are looking
very carefully at this and that it's
brought up the need for them to take it
more seriously because we know that
there's going to be more and more of
these disasters so thank you for the
bill
okay
and we have a representative Susie is
good afternoon Madam chair I'm
representative Susan trelelevin and I'm
sitting in for a representative and
thank you for welcoming me yes to your
committee thank you I know I've seen you
but your name just keeps slipping out of
my mind
all right so
all right in that case the motion is
inexpime to legislate by representative
a bear on House Bill 84 and the clerk
and call the roll
representative Simon yes
representative Lakers yes representative
Bailey yes representative Santo nostaso
yes representative true yes
representative Dolan yes representative
yes representative Gerhard yes
clerkboat yes representative yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative groda I have goalie yes
Roseanne Stewart yes
representative O'Brien
yes
representative soucy yes representative
Davis
yes representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative Gould
yes representative true 11.
yes
pronunciation
at 28-09
and the chair I'm sorry I'm sorry she's
I suppose I should vote Yes since you
already counted sorry I apologize madam
so I'll vote Yes okay
does does anyone have an objection to
consent
all right seeing none we'll put that one
on consent
twenty to zero
he counted me before I voted that's all
that's voter fraud oh and and uh
I'd like to mention that house bill 278
is on the list by mistake we've already
voted on that and uh
House Bill 258 representative a bear
again
thank you madam chair I would like a
motion for OTP
with amendments
and which amendment is it and the
amendment number is thank you
2023-0698 H as in Harry
okay
all right
would you wish to speak to your motion I
would thank you madam chair
I believe this is a fantastic bill that
we can pass here in New Hampshire that
will establish certification for animal
chiropractors with no referral from
anyone and eliminating pain for an
animal that may be in that may need
and I'm very excited to
motion
otpa thank you
okay
so the is there any discussion on the
representative Schmidt I'm happy to
point out that uh that this is
definitely an urgent matter for people
who are in the situation of a suffering
of being animal owners that are
suffering or owners of animals that are
suffering
um and uh so the owners are suffering
too because uh trying to get to a
veterinarian I understand it's difficult
because there's a long waiting period
and uh and therefore uh all they they
are going to do is get referred is there
a cost in that uh and and the the animal
chiropractor these people are trained
and certified under the amendment
um and therefore we're going to get
relief for people for whom these animal
chiropractors are a solution uh and
absolutely uh it's necessary and the
sponsor of the bill uh will be delighted
I'm sure when she finds out that we're
okay
in that case the motion is to adopt
Amendment
0698h for House Bill 258
and the clerk can call the roll
representative Simon yes representative
Lakers yes representative Bailey yes
representative santoso yes
representative true yes representative
Dolan yes representative yes
representative Gerhard yes the clerk
votes yes
representative groda yes representative
Schmidt yes representative goalie yes
representative shuitt yes representative
O'Brien yes representative Susie yes
representative Davis yes
representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative Gould yes representative
um true 11 yes
and the chair yes
20 years
okay the we've adopted the amendment the
motion is ought to pass with amendment
by representative a bear seconded by
representative Schmidt is there any
all right seeing none in that case the
clerk will call the roll when ready
representative Simon yes
representative lakis yes representative
Bailey yes representative Santo estaso
yes representative true yes
representative Dolan yes representative
yes representative Gerhard yes clerk
votes yes representative yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
shuitt yes representative O'Brien
yes representative Susie yes
representative Davis yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes representative Gould yes
representative 11 yes
and the chair yes
yes 20 yeah
the motion passes and the objections to
consent
none
all right seeing none we'll put that on
consent
on House Bill 274 that was
representative shuitt
subcommittee and I believe the motion is
to retain
and I'll make that motion
a second
and the reason we're retaining it is
that it's a fairly complicated bill with
a major revision to the rulemaking
process
some parts of it are unconstitutional
and therefore we're not going to pass it
as is but we think we can work on some
so retaining it seems like the easiest
way to deal with it
any
representative grotta do you wish to
speak to your second nope it's pretty
good okay anybody else want to discuss
it
okay in that case the motion is to
retain house bill 274.
representative Simon yes representative
Lucas yes representative Bailey yes
representative San Antonio
yes representative true yes
representative Dolan yes representative
Aber yes
representative Gerhard yes clerk votes
yes representative groda yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
shewitt yes representative O'Brien yes
representative soucy yes representative
Davis yes representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative Gould yes representative
true 11 yes and the chair yes
20 a zero name
are in retain we don't have to decide
what calendar goes on
um
representative schuett you have a motion
on House Bill 284.
yes Madam chair
um let me pull it out here
I would move
Amendment zero six uh two twenty twenty
three zero six four five
which I believe you all have somewhere
okay
and I'll second that
thank you I will point out that this
amendment is basically the amendment
that we had before us uh when we had the
non-germain amendment hearing the only
addition is section 6 because during
that hearing it was pointed out by the
administrator of the Hillsborough County
nursing home that there if you will
recall there were many items that
Hillsborough County has to do to go to
bid and unfortunately this one line line
30 in this amendment was left out of
that Amendment so the new amendment is
basically what you saw before adding
okay
I have nothing to say
any
excellent job thank you the motion is to
adopt Amendment 0645 and the clerk can
call the rule
representative Simon yes representative
Lakers yes representative Bailey yes
representative Santo mustacho yes
representative true yes representative
Dolan yes representative yes
representative Gerhard
clerk both yes representative groda yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie
yes representative shewitt yes
representative O'Brien
yes representative soucy yes
representative Davis yes representative
Fitzpatrick yes representative Gould yes
and the most and uh a motion of ought to
pass with amendment is yes I I will make
that motion
um and just say that the underlying Bill
House Bill 284 which the amendment just
adds the language to the underlying Bill
we heard if
bidding proposal details are made public
at times that can
how shall I say disadvantage or
Advantage people who previously bidded
so this language would protect that a
little bit so that they can get a fair
bidding process if they come back with a
okay
okay rep second by representative goalie
replaces the whole building no no the
amazing does not replace the whole build
sorry
yeah I thought that the
the basic Bill clarified that
non-confidential information
can be revealed in the course of a bit
such as
we didn't we canceled the the
solicitation because all the bids were
too high or what this the schedule would
be or something like that
no information about other bidders or
other bids right about the process yes
we heard that uh sometimes that could
dampen uh competitiveness
okay
um in that case the motion is ought to
pass with Amendment on House Bill 284
and by representative schuette and the
clerk can call the rule
representative Simon yes representative
leicus yes representative Bailey yes
representative yes
representative true yes representative
Dolan yes representative a bear yes
representative Gerhard yes clerk Lodge
yes representative grotta yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
schuette yes representative O'Brien yes
representative soucy yes representative
Davis yes representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative Gould yes
representative Trey Levin yeah
and the clerk
I mean I'm sorry in the chair gosh
28-09 is okay the motion passes 20-0 any
uh objection to consent
all right we'll put that one on consent
also
uh House Bill 358 being my bill I'm
going to move ought to pass with
Amendment and I don't have
do we have that Amendment here yet
no okay is that the amendment that I
gave
me yes that was a different one I had
if you'll excuse all right we'll we'll
come back to this one when I go fetch
ah no that's animal chiropractors 258
358 350 350 sorry 358 258 we've already
done that's under control we will come
back to this after our first break when
I can go fetch the amendment because I
think it's in my desk
there we go
uh house bill 359.
uh representative Bailey I think you
I move that we uh vote in expedient to
legislate on HB 359.
is there a second I'll second all right
do you wish to speak to your motion
um I guess I would be in favor of Ito
because it's uh not in perfect alignment
with article 10 in that it's just a
select group of people that would get
this holiday
although I like the idea and concept I
don't think it's practical
yeah I I I'm opposed the idea the
election is in fact election day is in
fact a legal holiday but
I don't know who it doesn't matter who
gets it off because
most of us are
busy going going out to vote for it so I
don't see that adding the presidential
primary or the general primary as
holidays would have any effect
whatsoever
Sam Gerhard thank you at least well not
least the last paragraph though all
other employers shall when practicable
allow employees up to three hours away
from work to cast ballots it just seems
kind of odd shall is enforcement thing
you have to but who's enforcing that and
how it just yeah so I'm agree with with
you I just find it kind of
sketchy okay
all right any further discussion
seeing none in that case emotion is an
experience to legislate on House Bill
359 by representative Bailey and the
clerk will call the roll
representative Simon yes representative
Lakers yes representative Bailey
yes representative Santo nastasso yes
representative true yes representative
Dolan yes representative a bear yes
representative Gerhard yes clerk Road
Jess representative groda yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
shewitt yes representative O'Brien yes
representative soucy yes representative
Davis yes representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative Gould
yes representative true 11 yes and the
chair yes
28-09
that motion passes 20-0 is there any
objection to consent
all right seeing none we'll put that on
consent
House Bill 457 we will
defer until Friday
House Bill 461 representative Simon
thank you madam chair I would like to
2023-0782h second okay
do you wish to speak to your motion uh
yes please
um so essentially what the amendment to
this bill does is it uh reduces the
amount of people who could have been
affected by the original legislation to
high-level employees in both group one
and group two of the retirement system
so Fire Chiefs police Chiefs
superintendents principals uh positions
of the like and what it does is if a
municipality decides to move a full-time
person in one of those positions down to
a part-time position in order to avoid
spreading costs to other municipalities
because they're no longer paying into
the retirement system
it basically
uh and it basically requires that the
municipality continue to pay the ual
portion of that position as determined
over the average of the last few years
and then uh 20 percent
penalty on top of it that would stay in
effect for 15 years or until the
position was reinstated to a full-time
position
and so it seems like a pretty Common
Sense measure to me uh to keep
municipalities from making decisions
that is basically going to force higher
expenses onto other municipalities the
amendment number again it is zero seven
eight two
okay representative Schmidt do you wish
to speak to your second
this is a practice which is unfair uh to
all the other communities in in the
State uh and therefore uh and harmful to
the uh uaal situation as well so uh we
don't want to let this spread so I'm
supportive of the bill as amended with
Amendment
other uh
their comments
I'd like to say that that I've seen it
happen and it's it's done by
well in some cases
the town may feel that they've got a
superior person that they that thinks he
can do it but it's very difficult to
realistically say you're replacing a
full-time superintendent or police chief
or a director of of your city operations
with a part-time position
it's
particularly with the Limited hours that
retirees from our our Lim are limited to
there's just no way that you can do the
job in that little time
without violating the
your
limits on hours and it's
it's unfair to other towns and it's
unfair to the people of that town when
the the high level persons coming back
from retirement
is unable to
fully perform the job within the hours
they're allowed to work
so
this closes a loophole that in some
cases towns have said that well it's
cheaper we don't you know we only have
to give them a part-time salary with no
benefits so they don't have to pay into
retirement
and
however advantageous that seems to be
for one town it is not advantageous for
I agree and uh you know even if it it is
workable for them to come part-time we
should remove the incentive for them to
do so and then they can make that
decision based on the merits not trying
to save pain into the uaal
good point all right
anyone else
representative Schmidt well one of the
aspects is when you're in a top position
like this ordinarily you're expected to
work independent of the clock and to be
available on a virtually full-time basis
whenever you're needed because you are
the top dog
okay now to put that person into a
part-time situation where they're
expected to work less is a contradiction
in terms of what people have a right to
seeing none the motion is to adopt
and the clerk who told the role
representative Simon yes representative
lakis yes representative Bailey yes
representative centenostaso yes
representative true yes representative
Dolan yes representative yes
representative Gerhard yes clerk both
yes
yes representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
schuett yes representative O'Brien yes
representative Susie yes representative
Davis yes representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative Gould yes representative
thank you madam chair I would like to
move otpa on House Bill 461. second
okay since the amendment replaces the
bill that makes sense
the motion is ought to pass with
Amendment on House Bill 461 and the
clerk and call the rule representative
Simon yes representative lakis yes
representative Bailey yes representative
Santo nastasso
yes representative true yes
representative Dolan yes representative
a bear yes representative Gerhard yes
the clerk beau's yes representative
groda
yes representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
shewitt yes representative O'Brien yes
representative Susie yes representative
Davis yes representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative Gould yes representative
true 11. yes and the chair yes
yes 20 years RNA
okay
um motion passes 20-0 any objections to
consent
uh it has a fiscal note but uh
hmm
it hasn't been amended uh okay we will
not put it on consent because of that
okay it representative Santa Ana salsa
you have a motion on House Bill 507.
uh yes I move uh ought to pass for house
bill 507.
representative uh Lucas all right Jews
just speak to your motion uh yes please
uh so this bill strengthens uh State
Licensing compliance uh For Occupational
licensing uh while avoiding
protectionism and allows voluntary
interaction between individuals uh
deletes the penalties for operating
without an occupational license and uh
prohibits people to be holding
themselves out to be licensed therefore
slipping the incentive from concealing
your unlicensed status to to wanting to
unconceal that and uh Market forces just
like they do now will continue to uh
Mark Force like insurance for example
will still demand occupational licensing
especially in fields like medical
construction
for the same reasons they do now you
can't get insurance policy if you have
unlicensed people on staff
thank you okay representative wish to
speak to your motion I do
um in addition to those
um you know there's
attempts or arguments for uh
removing certain licenses this actually
involves some of the complications it
leaves them in place if people need them
for some reason or want them or they
think that their customers would prefer
them they're available
um and um if they don't they don't
I know when I go to look for a doctor
for example I do quite a bit of
searching online and I may look and see
what certifications they have and they
have the things on the wall and what
medical schools have gone to they care a
lot more about that sort of thing than I
do about some state license and that's
true for
I'll be voting against the igl motion
although it sounds like
I mean I'm sorry I'm so sorry it's been
I don't know what's my it's been too
long of a day for me I'm sorry I'll be
voting against the OTP motion thank you
because
um
although
um I can understand people's
motives and um to um in how they operate
we have to remember that we're
representing the people of New Hampshire
and I feel that the there's been a lot
of discussion on licensing as will be
evident later on this afternoon and I
feel that if we want to look at
licensing and regulations and
certifications we should look at them in
relation to the industry that they're
related to and not across the board like
this thank you okay thank you
representative Gerhard thank you madam
chair
I'm supporting this
for the reason that the recent well the
recent events with covid have
demonstrated that
their
certain elements have been captured by
the the people that they should be
regulating and I'm specific specifically
talking about the medical industry where
you had doctors and nurses that were
prescribing treatments that were not
authorized by the bought and paid for
entities and they were threatened with
revocation of their ability to earn a
living and pay to pay their rent
mortgage whatever and I just think it's
dangerous and I don't think that's a
good precedent to maintain so I believe
that people should be held
or should people should have the ability
to go to the service provider they
choose to go to so long as Matt was
saying the representative sentence was
saying that they do not hold themselves
out to be licensed by the state
so personal responsibility individual
what to pass by representative San
Antonio
and the clerk can call the roll
yes
representative Lucas yes
representative Bailey yes
representative Santo nastasso yes
representative true yes representative
Dolan yes
representative a bear yes
representative Gerhard yes
clerk Road Jess representative groda
no representative Schmidt no
representative goalie no
Representative schuette no
representative O'Brien
no
representative Susie no representative
Davis no
representative Fitzpatrick no
representative Gould no
the motion fails on a tie is there
another motion yes
I move itl on house level 507. is there
a second
second there's some goalie seconds all
right
um
all right in that case the motion is
inexping to legislate on House Bill 507
and the clerk can call the roll
representative Simon no
Representative no
representative Bailey no representative
Santo nastasso no
representative true no
represent Senator Dolan no
Representative no representative Gerhard
no clerk votes no
representative groda yes representative
Schmidt yes representative goalie yes
representative shuitt yes representative
O'Brien yes representative soucy yes
representative Davis yes
representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative Gould yes
all right that motion also fails on a 10
on a tie therefore it will go with no
recommendation representative Santo
nastasso will write oh actually has
written the report for ought to pass uh
represent Broder you'll write for an itl
okay
incidentally I would like to very much
thank representative Santo nastasso and
the other people who sent in their
committee reports prior to the to the
meeting so we're way ahead of schedule
House Bill 339 representative groder you
oh is this the uh the wonder who they
heard this morning yes it is yes I move
itl and house bill 339.
second okay by representative
representative lacques
if I don't have to I'd rather not speak
to emotion
because I think based on the testimony
it's self-evident why the Bills should
be ideals
okay uh
let me just take that back I feel like
this morning we've heard we heard enough
about the subject that's that's why I'm
okay
I would have to uh agree with you
actually I do yes representative Gerhard
thank you
I will be voting itl on this as well and
I just want to
kind of elucidate my reasons for that
and one of the
members of public that satisfied earlier
talked about the incident in 1967 where
Israel attacked the USS Liberty
34 Sailors were killed 173 were wounded
in action and there's been no
investigation of this that was
legitimate so I just feel that there are
reasons that people are boycotting and I
don't think it's for some kind of
obscure reasons they actually have
legitimate reasons and I think we should
respect that and not
keep the state from investing in these
well the interest of fair disclosure
I'll say that not only do I have
relatives in Israel I've invested in a
number of Israeli companies
and
and I still support the itl because I
believe that we should not
tie the hands of our retirement system
with
political agendas however much we may
support them
representative I agree with that and
just briefly
um it's a bad precedent to set because
there are many different potential
political agendas that people might want
to influence the investment and the
other thing is that putting constraints
on them may reduce the return and even
every small bit of reduction in Return
of the pension system is costing just
about every taxpayer in the state money
anyone else
okay
in that case the motion is inexpedient
to legislate on House Bill 339 and the
clerk can call the roll
representative Simon no
excuse me representative lakis yes
representative Bailey yes representative
Santo nastasso yes
representative true nay
representative Dolan
Representative no
representative Gerhard yes
look vote to know representative groda
yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes
representative shewitt yes
representative O'Brien yes
representative soucy yes
representative Davis yes
representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative Gould yes
yes
15 yay 5 nay
all right the motion passes 15 to 5 that
will be on the regular calendar
is anyone interested in writing a
okay representative a bear will write a
okay
House Bill 518 Jackie that emotion I do
and I'm chair I'd like to retain house
bill 518.
I'll second that
you would just speak to your motion
yes I think that um
this is a one of these um bills that you
need a little bit more attention and we
should certainly spend some time looking
I'd like to say that it addresses the
idea of regulation of licensed
occupations and we have a couple of
major
major bills that we're looking at that
we obviously have not
looked at as thoroughly as we might like
in some areas and this bill could very
legitimately be amended to address some
of these revisions that were
really haven't had the time to do right
now
okay
in that case the motion is to retain
House Bill 518 and the clerk can call
the role
representative Simon yes representative
Lakers yes representative Bailey yes
representative Santo nastasso yes
representative true yes representative
Dolan yes representative a bear yes
representative Gerhard yes Kurt vote
Jess representative groda yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes
representative shuitt yes representative
O'Brien
yes
representative soucy yes representative
Davis yes representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative Gould
yeah 28 zerornay
all right the motion passes and the
chair
and the chair I'm going to vote a vote
Yes
I'm sorry
that's okay
yes I was thinking very hard at him I
didn't
all right
okay House Bill 532 representative a bar
you have a motion
thank you madam chair
I would like a motion to kill I'm sorry
itl HB 532 FN
and I'll second all right sorry
thank you we're moved by representative
second of everything like us you should
speak to your motion
I would thank you madam chair
in subcommittee I supported this and I
went home that weekend and I tossed and
turned on this forever
and the the main reason why I supported
it is because I'm pro-business I made
that very clear
however I think that we're using
Licensing in a different way here as
well as setting a precedent for other
Industries to say well I want to be
licensed so that I can obtain insurance
it's it's not the way that we use
Licensing in New Hampshire
also with the pending bills coming at us
with licensing
it's
most likely the insurance companies are
going to start to
require certification instead of
Licensing is is where I think this is
going
so
that is my motion thank you
representative do you have anything to
add
um I agree and the only other thing I'll
say is that I think the only legitimate
reason for occupational licensing and I
believe this is in statute
is related to health and safety and uh
from that's not the case really here I
mean we had a little bit of testimony on
that but I think the uh the bar for
health and safety to require licensing
is much much higher than applies in this
case
I wanted to say I am going to
um
vote against the ideal motion I think
that um
the there is tremendous benefit to be
gained by the um
by this practice and especially we heard
from those individuals who have been
affected from
being in uh in on the front and there's
the benefits to the veteran vets
veterans which I think is very important
and I don't think that it's up to us to
decide how hard how high the bar should
be when it comes to the benefits when we
ourselves do not recognize the benefit
um and I also think that the music
therapist and the speech pathologists
have been working together
in Earnest to get this bill to where it
is and therefore I think that that and
Licensing is how you get insurance
reimbursement in New Hampshire so I
think that this is
um a bill that deserves
um
to be brought to the floor
and I'll be voting against the itl
motion
representative goalie
thank you Mr chair and I too will be
voting against the motion of inexperiod
to legislate
we were all most of us were here for the
public hearing and heard how
this
is a different type
of treatment that affects people in
different ways helps some people a lot
and the problem that bothered me was
a number of individuals had to pay out
of pocket for this
and when I look at veterans with PTSD or
whatever they may have and this is a way
of helping in a form of treatment and
these individuals are paying out of
their pocket bothers me
and if we can do something to help
especially at a time not only with PTSD
or any of that at a time when there is a
mental health crisis in this country and
then this is another form of treatment
addressing that issue and we've heard
time and time again that this should be
an all hand Hands-On deck to help treat
Mental Health
that I cannot support in expedient to
legislate this is another tool in the
toolbox and I think it's important to
have that available and paid for and
covered so I will go against the Ito
thank you okay representative Schmidt
thank you madam chair and while they say
mu the hath charms to soothe the Savage
there are as a common recognition that
music has a strong impact on people
it can fire you up it can calm you down
or whatever but that doesn't mean that
you can be a therapist just by playing a
record
and are playing an instrument for that
matter although that probably is even
more soothing to some people depending
on the instrument
so the the other important reality is
this bill already passed the house
pass this committee passed uh I think it
passed the Commerce Committee as well uh
passed the house and would probably be
in law right now the pandemic hadn't uh
killed off the process in the Senate uh
so uh
we know that there are successful
businesses out there who are continuing
but they're struggling uh because uh
they
are not compensatable by insurance
simple matter the insurance doesn't say
you're bogus it just says you're not
licensed and so that's very unfair and
we're depriving our citizens of the kind
of treatment that other Sciences provide
for the simple music reason of uh of uh
not being covered by insurance and they
can't afford it otherwise
so at any rate
so I will also be voting against the
ideal
I said I'm sure thank you madam chair I
heard in committee that there are 48
music therapists in the state
and I cannot support a bill that is
written for a minuscule number of people
thank you
anyone else
okay
in that case the motion is inexpedient
to legislate on House Bill 532 and the
clerk can call the roll
representative Simon yes representative
yes representative Bailey yes
representative Santo nastasso yes
representative true yes representative
Dolan yes representative yes
representative Gerard yes
clerk vote Yes representative groda
no representative Schmidt no
representative goalie no
Representative schuette no
representative O'Brien
no
Representative soucy no
representative Davis no
representative Fitzpatrick no
representative Gould no
Representative 11. no
no and the chair
yes
Daniel
all right the motion fails on a tie is
there another motion
Madam chair I move OTP and Hospital
three four sorry
532.
yeah and I do have an amendment hang on
let me just
what is the amendment number
zero four eight zero
second
okay do you wish it well let's do we all
have the uh the amendment
well the amendment was um
is the is the final agreement between
the speech pathologists and the music
therapist and how specifically how they
would work in tandem on in a specific
case where they are in both involved
um
yeah all right we will recess this until
we until we can get copies of them you
have the amendment just a moment I may
have one copy we'll get more copies then
okay
will pause
all right and while while the
representative blackis or someone is
getting copies okay thanks I'm passing
out amendments the amendment to house
bill 358.
okay
yes yes that is an amendment that I
it was referenced earlier that she would
come up with the amendment
just just reminding everybody else but
representative bleckis okay was recalled
um
do you want to take a break for a few
minutes while he gets it or do you want
yeah let's go to 350 if that's okay with
I'm going to move ought to pass with
Amendment
0-400648
and I will mention that the amendment
replaces the
paragraph that was problematical in at
the hearing that is to send the notice
to the policy committee
and
a whole lot of other stuff that
um
look difficult to implement and simply
says that the rule making measure shall
be sent to all members of the general
court
so that ensures that everybody gets a
copy of it
if they are concerned about a rule
they're notified when it is being
when the initial draft is open for
public comment and they can comment
this will not cause any delays because
it is the public comment period
question of the chair yes sir isn't that
the case that this sending will be by
email yes sir yes
you didn't notice because you've already
get the rulemaking register but it's
been I believe two weeks since we tried
it out and so everybody should be
um Monday night I gave a lesson to the
HRA on how to read it
foreign
this and and I think it's appropriate
for uh everyone who's out there in the
universe was watching uh but especially
our colleagues on Edna uh but for that
matter all members of the house because
uh having served on the joint
legislative committee on administrative
rules for the past 16 plus years along
with representative McGuire for about
the last 10 or 12 of those years
um
the reality is that we are very very
seldom visited at a jail car meeting by
a member of the general court
either house or Senate and the rules are
it's a poorly understood science but
it's a very highly developed aspect and
we've had several bills dealing with
with rules uh here in Edna uh one of the
reasons I was put on gel car and Edna at
the same time 16 plus years ago but the
reality is uh because it's so poorly
understood there's a lot of
misconceptions about you know agencies
running amok or writing any rules they
like and so forth and so on and we we
may not all want to follow it as closely
as those who who are chained the gel car
wheel uh voluntarily or involuntarily
but we we ought to know more about it in
on this committee for sure but it ought
to be available so people at least have
an idea that is out there that they can
look and they can see what what this
process is like
and and therefore they will understand
it better they will be available maybe
one over two of them will want to get up
on an extra Friday and come in or
Thursday during vacation week a vacation
period and come and visit us and see
that this is an Earnest uh effort on the
part of the administrative rules unit
the agencies the Departments and the
members of the general court who serve
on the jail car both in the Senate and
the house so these are steps in that
direction without complicating your life
you don't have to look at it if you
don't want to but you might learn
something so I recommend it thank you
I'd like to continue that the rulemaking
register being sent to everyone deals
with a lot of the issues of sending it
to the policy committee because people
may be concerned about a rule I mean the
committee may have passed a bill but the
sponsor wasn't necessarily on that
committee and there may be other people
who know something about it
that could really help the
develop the make sure the rule meets the
legislative intent
the other Chan the amendment also adds
the requirement
that when the agency files the final
rule
they have to include a report on the
public comments and an explanation of
how they were addressed
they don't have to follow the comments
they just have to acknowledge that they
got them and what they did
some departments do this now Des is
exemplary
other departments don't but it's always
valuable to know who commented
and what the comments and concerns were
and how the agency addressed it I mean
I've seen differences from oh they
pointed this out and we said marvelous
idea let's do it
to well we think that we think we're
right and they're wrong and we ignored
it so anything in that range
is reasonable but at least when the jail
car is evaluating the rule they'll
they'll know what what the public
thought or at least those that cared
enough to comment
all right and and there's a a minor
technical correction in the amendment to
um
change
one of the deadlines to agree with other
parts of 541a
any
is there any other discussion on the
yeah I've talked too long all right the
motion is to adopt Amendment
0648 to House Bill 358 and the clerk can
call the roll
representative Simon yes
representative yes representative Bailey
yes representative Santo nastasso yes
representative true yes representative
Dolan yes representative yes
representative Gerhard yes
representative groda
representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
shuitt yes representative O'Brien yes
representative soucy yes representative
Davis yes representative of Fitzpatrick
yes representative Gould yes
representative true 11. yes
and the chair yes
20 years
hey the amendment is adopted and I move
passage of House Bill 359 with Amendment
0648.
didn't I say that
uh
358 excuse me I'm
feeling clueless that was by me second
by representative Gould
I think it was a tie in favor of it well
representative Schmidt you've seconded a
lot today so we should let
representative Gould get her her name in
I'm gonna go sulk in the corner very
good
quietly I hope
all right the motion is to adopt uh or
to pass with Amendment on House Bill
358. his and is there any further
discussion
all right in that case the clerk can
call the roll
representative Simon yes representative
yes representative Bailey
yes representative Santo nastasso yes
representative true yes representative
Dolan yes representative yes
representative Gerhard yes quick protest
representative groda yes representative
Schmidt yes
representing goalie yes rip represent
them shoe it yes representative O'Brien
yes
representative Susie yes representative
Davis yes representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative Gould yes
representative 11. yes and the chair
yes
20 years consent the motion uh passes
20-0 any objections to consent not from
representative Schmidt I can see okay
anyone else all right we'll put that one
on consent
thank you for not having to explain it
to people
all right and we have now the amendment
did I did I confuse the process that was
that the amendment we just adopted
you did interrupt my my explanation of
what the amendment did but that's okay
um
so back to house bill 532 with Amendment
0480 representative groda you wish to uh
discuss this
thank you madam chair so the amendment
was written is the finalization of the
agreements between the speech therapists
and the music therapists
um in and specifically the parts that
were added were claws
let me just see three which I'm
collaborating with the individual lives
family service plan or individualized
education program team to review the
students diagnosis treatment plan
this is this is the music therapy and
the um
speech theologists working together on
that this was language that was inserted
in this specifically at the request of
the speech pathologists
and
and then number five collaborating with
And discussing the music therapy
treatment plan with the audiologist or
speech language pathologist of a client
with communication or disorders during
the provision of Music Therapy Services
so this is the kind of this is that's
what that's how this bill of men's house
second was it I was
yes represent Gould you should speak to
your second
yes
um I really support this amendment and
Jackie thank you for doing such great
okay
all right representative Schmidt and
representative thank you thank you thank
you ma'am sure I think uh um everyone
should understand that uh one of the
only impediments to the successful
passage of the bill uh earlier in in the
uh not this legislature but previous to
the pandemic
was that the speech pathologists and the
music therapists were in a little bit of
a turf war with regard to who does what
and where the where the Venn diagram
crossed over or whatever uh but but the
two two uh former adversaries who always
had lots in common in terms of working
for the benefit of people with various
different health issues
um and and they have come together and
this amendment is crucial toward the uh
toward the the bill being whole and and
containing all the aspects that it needs
to so I think it's important that we
have adopted the amendment uh and uh so
okay representative blackest thank you
um although I plan on voting um against
the otpa I'm actually going to vote to
support this amendment um given the
current circumstances there's a
reasonable chance this bill's uh going
to be adopted
and if so
um I think it should be with this
amendment I want to thank represent
grota for working in the subcommittee
uh for and sorting this out between the
two groups and
um I don't think it in the overall
scheme of things would make it
significantly more likely the bill is
going to pass but if it does pass I'd
like to see it with the amendment
thank you anyone else
representative
thank you madam chair I'll just say
we've we've dealt with this subject for
seems quite a few years in this
committee and uh as representative
Schmidt indicated the issues between the
speech pathologists and the music
therapists always arose and this looks
like a pretty good compromise and
cooperation between those two so I
definitely will be supporting this
0480h to House Bill 532 and the clerk
and call the roll
representative Simon yes representative
lakis yes representative Bailey yes
representative Santo nastasso yes
representative true
yes representative Dolan yes
representative a bear yes representative
Gerard yes clerk folk yes representative
yes representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
shewitt yes representative O'Brien yes
representative soucy yes representative
Davis
representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative Gould yes
representative treeleven yes and the
chair yes
28-0
all right the motion is adopted
representative you
second all right that's spirit and
Schmidt
okay representative Schmidt
okay anyone else have a comment question
Maybe
technology
okay and I'll I'll be a little briefer I
just wanted to say I was really touched
by the veteran who came in and testified
at the committee and I think this is a
really important service for a lot of
people in our society but especially I
have a heart for our veterans and that
for people in business whether we
support our current health care System
the way it's organized the way Insurance
set up there's other remedies if we
disagree with that but to the extent
that's what what we have that music
therapists need to be able to get
reimbursed so that people of all income
levels especially our vets can have
anyone else representative Gerhard
thank you madam chair
I'm just a little concerned about so at
the end of the day somebody's paying for
the insurance
and at 150 to 180 an hour that's what I
have the notes from the initial hearings
it just seems excessive but besides that
I'm just curious as to if Insurance can
cancel coverage for this service I don't
know where that is legally but that's my
concern and I'll just put that out there
so uh private insurance can do whatever
they want essentially within within the
scope of what we've mandated they've
covered but I this I believe would be
optional representative blackis yeah we
heard that in the subcommittee that I
mean this doesn't require
private insurance or anything else to
cover it it just says if they cover it
they they generally want
licensing so that's why it's there okay
okay the motion is ought to pass with
Amendment on House Bill 532 and the
clerk can call the roll
representative Simon no
representative
representative Bailey
representative Santo nastasso
representative true
representative Dolan no representative a
bear no representative Gerald no
clerk votes no representative grotta yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
shuitt yes representative O'Brien yes
representative soucy yes representative
Davis yes
representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative Gould yes
representative treeleven yes and a chair
no
okay uh both
ought to pass and itl have failed on a
tie therefore it'll be going with no
recommendation uh representative a bear
will be writing the
report in favor of itl and
representative wrote it in favor of what
and
representative leckis has a motion yes
I'd like to move itl on this um
this is another one of these um
sorry I second okay it's another one of
these open uh free software things and I
I have certainly some sympathy there are
reasons to be concerned about
about having to run proprietary software
especially if you have to run it on your
own equipment and
during the public hearing it at least I
was confused initially it wasn't clear
and I thought that the fiscal note might
have been a little crazy however uh
afterward furthermore further testimony
I looked at the wording the language
carefully it it did apply more broadly
not only to the software run on people's
equipment but also everything on the
state side of it that people interacted
with and
you know that and whether the uh over
three years almost a billion dollar
fiscal node is excessive I don't know
but it's going to be huge anyway even if
it's not quite that and then on top of
it this applies to political
subdivisions including schools we never
even saw a fiscal note on what the cost
of that would be so I mean well there's
some value to pushing towards the use of
of open software it's not worth anywhere
near the cost of this thing
okay
I think representative Lucas covered it
very well okay
anyone else have a comment question
all right seeing none the motion is
inexpion to legislate on House Bill 617
and the clerk and call the rule
representative Simon yes representative
Lucas yes representative Bailey
yes
representative Santo nastasso yes
representative true yes
representative Dolan yes representative
clerk roaches representative groda yes
representative Schmidt
I was out of the room at the time the
motion was made thank you sir
representative goalie yes
representative shuitt yes
representative O'Brien yes
representative soucy
yes
representative Davis yes
representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative Gould yes representative
11. yes and the chair yes
18 yay one day
okay
the motion passes 18 to 1. is there an
was that okay no objection okay
um in that case what the will be put on
the consent calendar
and all right
it's the sponsor is always
okay so that was Bill 644
representative Lucas
oh yes I'd like to make a motion of
representative Joel in seconds okay
thank you
just to speak to your motion I do
um
so what this does is it it takes certain
shampooing curling styling
um
not cutting nothing like not cutting on
dying none of the harsh chemicals allow
application of cosmetics
and this thing called eyebrow threading
where they use a cotton thread to remove
hairs from the eyebrows in certain other
places on the face so those would not
require a license but all of the other
things
that are are you know potentially more
risky will still require a license
there's a second part to the bill
that was added at the request of oplc
and today if you have a salon you know
the people working there assuming
they're I mean today they have licenses
individual licenses uh
Barbara's con you know hairdressers
cosmetologists estheticians and all that
but then the salon owner also has a
facility license a salon license
but today let's say they have some extra
chairs and they want to rent it to
somebody
who at this point has an individual
license
to just practice in their Salon that
person may not have their own Salon
their own place to do it but they're
they're doing it not as an employee but
renting it
currently the way the statue is written
they have to go and get another whole
Salon license just for that chair within
what's already a licensed salon and
under the um the statute around Salon
licensing
the salon owner the holder of that
license is responsible for all the
activities that take place in the salon
and so oplc uh feels and I agree that
that that's redundant there's no need
for a separate license for this one
chair that's already within a licensed
Salon I think it's it's kind of a
oversight in the law
and that's that's it okay representative
Dolan do us to speak to your second
okay
any uh discussion representative uh
groda and then goalie I have a question
so
but this doesn't prevents someone from
opening up a business to just do blow
drying so it's it's more than just
involving the chair there's sort of two
separate issues here
um
because that was tacked onto this bill
so the Brenda of the chair if they're
doing things which are um
assuming this bill passes if they're
doing things that still require a
license they're cutting hair they're
doing dying they're doing any of those
things they'll still need an individual
license they just won't have to in
addition get a salon license
if this bill passes and the salon owner
rents the chair to somebody who's
limited to is limiting their practice to
what we would allow without a license
then they won't need an individual
license but they're still being overseen
by the salon owner because it says
they're responsible for what happens in
their Salon they could also
set up business somewhere else that's
not a licensed salon and do it on their
own and that's true
okay so I'd like to make a comment on
that this this is where I have an
objection to the bill if this was you
know a license if this involves
something within the salon and we had
somebody supervising all that I would be
okay with it but the fact that some
individual can open up a facility and do
this on their own is where I get
concerned about creep because there is
no way that
um if someone has a client who has just
washed their hair and dried it and that
clients wants a trim or she wants their
their bangs cut or something you know
their hair layered there is no way that
someone's gonna say oh I can't do that I
just don't see that and it's no it just
it's the client
um relationship that I think makes it
difficult for that person to say no and
there and what we're saying is they
can't do that but we're putting somebody
in a position where they may do that and
so that's my issue with this bill that's
my only issue with the bill
oh
I'm not sure interesting
first on blackest yeah I understand that
concern I mean but there's
you know a huge number of things that
people may do
um that they're not permitted to do I
mean somebody may cut their neighbor's
hair and get paid for it or something I
mean we don't
so
um and these activities that they are
allowed which I understand you're okay
with what people normally do at home I
understand the concern but I think that
that's
true in many many areas and restricting
what people can do based on their
representative Goldie
thank you madam chair I will be voting
against the emotion
um
I'm looking back at my notes and
I think being part of the subcommittee
the recommendation was to retain out of
the subcommittee five to nothing
um and I will be voting against
the ought to pass and support uh
hopefully this motion failing and the
emotion of retain coming forward because
I think this needs to be looked into a
little further I mean we discussed the
cosmetology part and the airbrushing and
some of the other factors in this that I
think can you know be a danger to the
public when you get around the face and
the eyes with airbrushing thank you okay
thank you representative Schmidt and
then gerhardt thank you ma'am chair so I
I I understand the arguments
representative leckis was making before
and I think I would support that aspect
of the letting the salon owner have a
independent and licensed person working
without a second license that to me is a
no-brainer but but and I and I really
don't have that much of a problem with
somebody washing hair or styling here
the the two issues that I do have
problems with where I think hygiene and
sanitation are not just oh well you know
I don't see it that way and that is
makeup for one thing when you're putting
when you're putting your hands on
somebody else's face uh and putting
makeup on them and so forth and the
possibilities I don't use makeup myself
unlike some other high-ranking
politicians
but but
the thing is when you're putting makeup
on people there's a possibility of
contamination as I understand it uh but
also this threading stuff where you're
putting something into somebody's
eyebrows and do they Yank on them or
something and pull out the eyebrows to
me that even if it's done by people who
learned it at home because it's part of
their cultural heritage
not all the people are going to be in
that category and I don't I I'm not
comfortable with letting people work on
somebody else's face that don't have the
necessary training and they ain't going
to get it if they're only going to be
doing hair washing shampooing and and
styling and so forth so I can't support
it in in the form it's being offered
thank you representative gerhardt
I've said this before
let me go to something I'm gonna say no
so last night for instance I was doing
kickboxing and we're putting hands and
feet on each other
nobody died nobody gets infections
because the guy he's an old school
brawler who's to teach whatever coach
instructor use Lysol wipes wipe your
stuff down and I've never heard of any
incidents of issues if there's maybe
somebody gets ringworm you write you
wrap duct tape around it you move along
you keep it moving I just think that
we're we're trying to get into this idea
that everybody is three years old and
has a room temperature IQ I think we
need to start treating people respect
and I mean I just I don't know I don't
see the idea of having scissors near
somebody's face as a reason to call the
police and and start setting you know
the reinforcements in I mean I'm a
carpenter I can build a house now yes
you have building inspectors that'll
check your work but we could do the same
thing we can make sure people leave in
the The Barbershop don't have Cuts all
over their face but I just can't
understand how in New Hampshire you
could build a house without having a
license but you need a license to cut
somebody's hair it just I'm just
confused so that's where I'll stand on
the contractors have powerful friends in
the in the legislature
yes thank you representative Gould
thank you madam chair
I went to cosmetology school and I did
send you all videos from YouTube on how
did the threading happens and the hair
washing so you'd know exactly how much
training I really want to support this
bill I'm going to vote no to the OTP but
I really hope we can do a retain and do
some work on it because I think with
just a little tweak and we can get it
over the finish line thank you okay
representative Lagos so first um uh
thank you representative goalie for
reminding me I should have mentioned uh
what happened in the subcommittee I just
forgot and that is uh
uh there was an attempt to OTP which
failed and then we did a retain which
was five to zero
um but I later heard from a member of
the subcommittee that changed their mind
on it which the OTP I think would have
passed in those circumstances so
that's why I went and brought forward
the OTP not not to try and get around
the the subcommittee so
um
representative
yes um
I'm inclined to support the OTP the
challenge that I or the
the challenge that I had in in this bill
was one of the chemicals
um or the fact that
every licensed cosmetologist has to
carry
per OSHA MSDS sheets on all chemicals in
their Salon I thought that was a
licensing
regulation when in fact it was an OSHA
regulation so
any shop that has any chemical shampoo
whatever it is they have to per OSHA
have the chemicals however I've not
gotten confirmation of that so you know
understanding the retain would be you
know something that I would support as
well thank you
okay
so anyone else I can just ask a process
question so
if we were to
um
devote OTP and it weren't to go through
could we decide to retain at that point
if the OTP motion failed then then
anyone can bring any other
appropriate not sure thank you
okay anyone else
in that case the motion is ought to pass
by representative leckis on House Bill
644 and the clerk can call the rule
representative Simon yes representative
yes representative Bailey yes
representative Santo nastasso yes
representative true yes representative
Dolan yes representative yes
representative Gerhard yes clerk vote
Yes Representative groda no
representative Schmidt no
representative goalie no
Representative shuitt no representative
O'Brien no
representative soucy no representative
Davis no
representative Fitzpatrick no
representative Gould
no
representative true 11 no and the chair
yes
the motion fails on a uh on a tie vote a
represent goalie you want to move retain
yes Madam chairman okay I'll second
okay
do you wish to speak to the motion
no I think enough has been said and for
the reasoning why in subcommittee that
was the vote so I'm hoping we uphold
that person would like us
um that's fine good anyone else have any
comments
questions
all right seeing none the motion is to
retain House Bill 644 and the clerk can
call the roll
representative Simon yes representative
yes representative Bailey yes
representative santoso yes
representative true
yes yes representative Dolan yes
representative Bear yes representative
Gerhard no
representative of uh me the clerk votes
no yes
representative groda
yes
represent goalie yes representative
shewitt yes representative O'Brien yes
representative Susie yes
representative Davis yes
representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative Gould yes representative
yes and I think you should get extra pay
for today you're doing a great job thank
you three hours of sleep
and the chair yes
19 yay one day all right house bill 644
is retained in committee and yet again
representative Goldie you don't do not
indeed
all right
and all
all committee reports are due in
and moving on to the last one house bill
655 representative Broda you have a
motion
I do
um I'd like to move Amendment
um
the amendment of do you want me to speak
to my amendment to emotion yes please
speak to your Marshall thank you so
House Bill 655 was quite a hefty bill
and when we found out that it was also
in House Bill 2
we thought it would be a good idea to
extricate the part of House Bill 655
which we felt could be addressed quickly
by this committee
and that is the chapter that's 310 and
Deals Only with oplc and codifies what
the agency does which took up
about
um 40 of the bill
so House Bill and so they there are
several there's a couple of components
to this which is different than the bill
that we originally saw if anybody
actually read the whole thing
um but there were some parts there were
some concerns raised during the
subcommittee about
um record retention and about
um uh privacy and those
um those um comments were added into the
amendment by oplc
and at this point we we I'm offering
this amendment as a way to pass House
Bill 655 in codifying what oplc does and
this part of the bill will be removed
from house bill 2. that's the plan
okay so we are going to replace the
Olive House bill
655 with this amendment
do you have anything to answer
um yes I'd like to say this this was my
bill it came out of the study committee
on oplc that I was on this summer
and what is it intended to do is to
clarify what the responsibilities and
duties of the office are
and what the responsibilities and duties
as amended it gives the structure and
setup of the oplc
it is much better than the original
version on
the subject of
investigations and discipline because it
includes a lot of the work that we had
in in specific
licensing board statutes
to differentiate between a formal
complaint that has to be reported to
your insurance to an allegation of
misconduct it in ensures that the
investigators
who are not necessarily board members
but they are qualified
experts that have sufficient knowledge
on appropriate statutes or professions
and their practices so that means if you
have an electrical an issue of improper
electrical work you'll have an
electrical inspector looking at it if
you have an allegation of medical
malpractice you'll have a doctor looking
at it
and so that's something that was brought
out as a concern at the hearing because
the simplified language that was there
before didn't specifically
address that as clearly as many people
would have wanted so I think the
amendment is a significant Improvement
and I hope you will adopt it
representative leckis thank you I just
have a question that so
the investigator who's the has some
expertise there the electrician the
doctor
are they a member of the board are they
an employee or contractor of oplc who
would that be normally a contractor okay
the board is going to be the jury
essentially the judge and jury
because and therefore they should not
necessarily be the universe that was my
representative Schmidt
thank you madam chair so uh I I have a
couple of questions number one is uh
this the the language of the amendment
which I'm just seeing now for the first
time
is the product of uh of the oplc itself
for the most part yes right and we I see
we have one of the attorneys from oplc
is here uh and so perhaps there will be
some other questions but I certainly
think this is a step in the right
direction uh uh I know there has been a
lot of pushback since we had the work
session
um last Tuesday which just a couple of
us were able to be here the chair
represents the right somebody was there
representative Wilhelm and I myself and
representative Davis were there but the
rest of us uh the rest of the committee
were largely you know on vacation very
often and something had been planned
quite a bit in advance and couldn't be
just uh you know thrown thrown away on
short notice but I got a lot of pushback
with regard to the 655 in terms of the
idea of repealing licenses and or
certifications yes I'm sorry that at the
hearing I didn't make it clear enough
that we weren't really talking about
House Bill 655. we were talking about
House Bill 2 but we didn't have the
exact language at that point we were
working on the concepts that the
governor and the oplc had put out saying
this is going to be in house bill 2. so
that was what we were talking about and
it confused a lot of people to thinking
they would be in 655 and that's probably
my fault I'm not faulting you madam
chair believe me I have no intent of
doing that whatsoever uh but I certainly
was one of the ones who was at least
partially confused and
um uh the the thing was that it was
stated several times well it looks like
it's going to be in the hospital too but
Hospital 2 wasn't out yet so we didn't
have it all we knew was a report an
allegation a statement that it was going
to be in House Bill too and of course
the idea of repealing all this kind of
stuff was anathema to me uh because I
don't I don't believe in that and I
certainly don't believe in putting it in
House Bill too anyway I got a lot of
pushback
and I reached out to a lot of people
because I wanted to find out whether
they had heard of it and and most of
them had but of course they hadn't seen
the language of Hospital 2 either wasn't
out so they couldn't
um but but uh and so my understanding is
that uh that the language the repeal
section of hospital this first of all
this will definitely come out of
Hospital too if this amendment is
adopted yeah well yes what
that's why we're meeting on Friday
afternoon I understand this ongoing
process but we're dealing with this
right now I have spoken
fine agreement in principle so
we take everything that's in house in
House Bill 655 out of house bill 2. so
that we don't have to try and keep them
synchronized
uh
because of that meeting
I was convinced that the
Landscape Architects and natural
scientists
excuse me needed to be licensed because
there was no other way to deal with the
fact that our
the Des regulations and are the state
and local regulations require a stamped
plan or whatever
and without any kind of a license
there's no way to decide who gets a
stamp
so I'm working on com on dealing with
that and taking that out of house bill
too because it the governor appears to
have
jump to conclusions on those those
professions
the other deletions I am not touching
because I can't I can't do everything if
and um
I think that it's those were the
governor's ideas he didn't consult with
us he didn't and therefore it's his job
to defend them
well I'm I'm very appreciative of uh of
your statement because I think you're
certainly heading in the right direction
uh there's no way I would support uh the
trailer bill with a repeal con section
in there that would strip away the
licenses even though the ones that were
in the news release that we received
from the office of Professional
Licensing and certification uh director
Courtney was
here at one point and she's not here can
I just make a comment we're supposed to
be talking about the amendment yes I
really would like to stick if it's okay
with you I'm sorry I'm an M chair yes
well I appreciate that and I I don't
have any problem with that but since
there's a lot of moving parts and I know
we're coming back on Friday yeah believe
it or not okay the day after tomorrow I
believe it uh so anyway let's proceed
and I will be here on Friday too
excellent thank you we'll be glad to see
you representative Gould
thank you madam chair and I just want to
thank you for this amendment I also have
gotten tons of feedback from my
community though I didn't ask for it but
um it's it's the only big volunteer yes
it's the only Bill I've heard and I've
heard a lot it matters to a lot of
people and I did watch the um hearing
live I watched you all that day you were
doing the committee meeting I just
didn't drive it so thank you all for the
work on this I think this is really good
just uh another question on the
investigation part so
oplc will be hiring or Contracting with
people with specialized expertise for
investigations I know there's no new
fiscal note but is there any guess as to
the magnitude I'm just concerned that
I don't know how many investigations
there are how many would take people
with expertise what it'll cost I just
I'm concerned of a situation where
licensing fees have to go up
substantially because of this
I might still support it but I'd like to
understand that
I'm not sure that this is the plan that
had been intended all along long that
they that the expert would be contracted
I believe that the medical board for
example hires outside experts right now
I don't know what the total anyway
anyway there there are
um
particularly in major K ish cases there
are issues with
people knowing each other it's such a
small state that it you might if you
have a serious case you might want to
hire an outside expert that doesn't know
sure I understand the concerns you start
getting the antitrust and other problems
and okay I just hopefully it's not going
to dramatically increase licensing fees
we have uh we have the attorney from the
uh open you'll see here would you care
to comment on that do you know about
that issue Mr osterhaus
since there's a specific question on it
Douglas toaster how excuse me general
counsel oplc uh we do have uh experts
right now it depends we have a couple of
experts in-house I believe like
mechanical mechanical engineers
pharmacists have their own experts other
boards such as medicine Dentistry
already have contractors and we always
have a specialist to do the
investigations already so we don't
expect this to increase costs for
licensees
okay great it's so nice to hear thank
you
represent crota I do want to make one
um we might and we might not remember
that we passed House Bill 445 which is
the lapsing fun part of the oplc and I
chose to leave that in the amendment
So eventually we'll have to do something
with this my
um my intention and I've spoken about
that with the chair of ways and means is
to once we have
voted on 445 to table it okay thank you
because that'll establish the house
position with without again
creating the nightmare of tracking two
different bills on the same subject
okay
in that case the motion is to adopt
amendment 0807 to House Bill 655 and the
clerk and call the roll
representative Simon yes representative
Lakers yes representative Bailey
yes representative santoso yes
representative true yes representative
Dolan yes representative yes
representative Gerhard yes clerk from
Jess representative Grotto yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
schuett yes representative O'Brien yes
representative Souci yes representative
Davis yes representative Fitzpatrick yes
representative Gould yes representative
yes
and the chair yes 20 a 0 and they
all right we've adopted the amendment
the representative
I move otpa on House Bill 655
since the amendment replaced the bill
we're both going to shut up at this
all right thank you very much the motion
is ought to pass with Amendment on House
Bill 655 Network and pull the rule
represent Simon yes representative
Lakers yes representative Bailey yes
representative santoso yes
representative true yes representative
Dolan yes representative Bear yes
representative Gerhard yes clerk vote
Yes representative grotta yes
representative Schmidt yes
representative goalie yes representative
shewitt
yes representative O'Brien yes
representative Susie yes representative
Davis yes Representatives Fitzpatrick
yes representative Gould yes
representative Dr Levin yes and the
chair yes
28-09
motion passes
20-0 is there any objection to consent
it's got an FN is that I don't know if
what we know
um
I think I will try and put it on consent
and if the clerk or the speaker decides
it's too expensive they'll pull it off
thank you all for your
support and efficiency I'm impressed we
got through this soon the uh
committee reports are new in
as soon as possible tomorrow we will
meet
um we're in session
and uh
we will be in on Friday to exec the two
and have us oh
a work set a worked session and
discussion on
what I'm struggling to put to do with
house bill 2.
the other point is that next Wednesday
the 15th we have five bills
uh to have public hearings
and I intend to exec all of them during
that day because
first of all the deadline's the 16th and
secondly that I've saved up some nice
easy ones that we should be able to make
up our minds on right after the hearing
so uh we will be exacting
those bills and if we do manage to do
all of them we won't have to come back
until we get some Senate bills so I hope
hope everyone will cooperate with that
effort
anything else
yeah yeah
tomorrow we're in session
I believe it starts at 10 o'clock it's
normal
I no no no that would be wrong
the majority leader would kill me if I
tried to schedule a subcommittee in in
conflict with caucus Madam chair you did
indicate that you had to announce
something on Friday announce on the
house floor tomorrow I will announce the
executive session on those two bills and
it will be at
um
is representative Simon going to tie a
bow around your fingers I've already
told the clerk and he's he's expecting
okay but we wouldn't want to forget that
that so that uh if you're not on the
subcommittee
we will be resuming with the exact
session at quarter to two
on the uh on Friday for those two bills
and then we'll go into the information
session so I know there's some
activities on Friday morning involving
us uh but just for your information as
you probably know the jcec with
representative leckis and me in our
original go around and meeting at one
o'clock yeah quick meeting I hope that's
that's why I'm scheduling the exec to
begin a quarter to two rather than one I
realize there there's always some some
coordination going on so I appreciate
attention it's pension subcommittee it's
got two bills that we didn't vote on
it and Carol yes just want to verify
that all of the committee reports that I